Hello. What the fuck
is going on? Everybody?
This episode of the Joe Rogan
experience podcast is brought to you by
audible.com have you used audible.com?
What are you doing? Are you just sitting
in traffic like a fucking savage?
Just listening to nothing or making
yourself listened to those assholes on the
radio? They're not all assholes.
Some of them were very nice guys,
but I have to say that for the
purposes of this commercial,
I don't even have to say it,
I just did it.
audible.com is the best resource for
audio entertainment on the Internet.
They have over 150,000
titles, uh, audio books.
And they also have this whisper
sync thing that you can use with uh,
the kindle fire HD. It's a pretty
dope where you listened to, um,
a audio book and then it
syncs up to your kindle.
So then you can read like up to a certain
point and you get tired and you're
like, ah, but I want to finish this book.
You can listen to it on the way to work.
It's incredible.
So he can read it and listen to it.
It's a pretty smooth operation.
That's a, that's a very smart, uh,
ingenious invention. And, um,
if you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you'll get one free audio book and 33
days of audible service. And as I said,
they have 150,000 titles. They have
comedies, they have, what does that,
that's that thing that the homeland guys
doing. Yeah. How's that going again?
I have no idea. He's doing like, and
the, the, the lead guy from homeland,
what is his name? Brody.
But what is his real name?
Glen got Gary's. Isn't that weird?
Like that guy's pretty famous.
No one knows what the fuck name is.
Damian Lewis. Yeah. Hell of an actor.
Except he sucks pretending
that he's tired.
Like when he runs up and he's pretending
to run out of breath, he's terrible.
Oh my God.
Joey d is running out of breath.
He's like a black belt in acting and a
white belt and pretending to be like out
of breath. I would totally do it. Joey.
Joey's out of breath all the time.
Joe Rogan.
There's no need to get fucking
all uppity with your cardio.
audible.com forward slash Joe Gaze,
a free audio book and 33 days of audible
service. We recommend them very highly.
Uh, they've, uh, they've always
been very cool and they uh,
voices supported standup comedy as well.
There's so many different
things to get on,
including the opie and Anthony Radio
show and it's an awesome resource.
audible.com forward slash show
go get yourself some free shit,
son more or else we're also
brought to you by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a,
a great way for you to incorporate
yourself for you to start a will.
You can even get divorced. Okay.
And you just do it online. Uh,
it's pretty amazing.
You can go to legalzoom.com and take care
of a lot of shit that you used to have
to go to an actual lawyer for.
You know,
he used to you a lot of money
that's not necessary anymore.
And if you do panic, if you get to a point
you're like, fuck, I'm going to jail,
they can connect to you with
an independent attorney.
If you need additional guidance. So if
you get to a certain point, you're like,
this just seems fucked. I can't, I'm
too stupid for this. You bail legal.
Zoom is not a law firm.
What they do is they provide self help
services at your specific direction,
but it's super easy to do. That's
how on it was incorporated. Uh,
Brian's used them to incorporate,
you can get a will for 69 bucks.
You can incorporate, you can form an
LLC for just starting at 99 bucks.
It's beautiful. They can tell they can
take care of trademarks, copyrights,
patents,
all that legal shit.
If you've got a great idea
and you want to protect it,
legal zoom can hook it out.
So check out legal zoom.com and use the
code named Rogan in the referral box at
checkout and save yourself some
more money. In the past 12 years,
over 2 million Americans have used legal
zoom and they've saved an ass load of
money. That's what it says on the thing.
It says, they say he's an asshole.
That's what the ad says. It's not what
it says, Brian. You don't even care.
I'm just making things up in this
commercial and you don't even care.
Is it legalzoom.com
use the codeword Rogan.
We're also brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com use the code name,
Rogan and on it also and save yourself
10% of any and all supplements.
We have a lot of shit other
than supplements on is what
we like to refer to as a
human optimization website. We just sell
shit that makes you work. Work better.
It makes your body work better,
makes your brain function quicker,
makes your endurance better.
Strength and conditioning equipment that
provides functional strength that that
really does translate
into athletic improvement.
There's a lot of exercises that people
do that don't translate really well into
sports.
Like how you have it, like they have packs
now. They have the caveman pack. Yeah,
we've always had stuff like that. That's
so funny. Oh, this is the new one. Okay.
I haven't seen that. Where's
that under? It's a, I don't know.
It was under supplements and they
have like, like these packs nowadays.
Rickles David came, man Rickles
you fights in Beltour. Oh,
okay. I get it. Well,
it's not a caveman package really like
us fighter that you guys sponsor and you
got, you're trying to blow them up, right?
Yeah, yeah. No, he was his nickname's man.
So that's why it's a caveman pack. Oh, get
it. Yeah. No, I got Dave Rickles cave man.
It was like on it. We have a caveman pack.
We have a, you know, gladiator pack. No,
his name is caveman.
And since we sponsor
him pack by Agra Shit,
you guys use that bell tour? 155 pound
weight class. A tricky way. Class, man.
We'll talk about that on the podcast.
Um, this is just the commercial part.
Use the code name Brogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
We also have primal bells,
kettle bells with awesome gorilla faces.
We gotta get you some for 10th Planet 10
plan of Bells. Yeah. You don't have, oh,
we have a new monkey too. We have a
new 18 pound monkey, a little baby,
a little howler monkey.
Plus we've got a Zombie coming
out and zombies should be best.
Tommy's going to be huge. I want to do
a Sasquatch, Sasquatch. It's 103 pounds.
You got to be cool is if you could
put hair all around that bar.
So when you look at it,
it looks like you're holding
like someone's hair and
like I turn around and the
edge of it, it's like someone
got to capitated. You're
doing, let me put the cap,
a sack.
It looks like you're just a fucking,
you got two of them and you're just
chopping heads off and shit with lab,
the impaler series and maybe we
can make a little wigs for them,
little wigs if you will.
That would be huge
wigs that you can put on.
And then the end has to be just
like skin hanging and stuff.
But it's got to be balanced though.
It's going to be hard.
Well really good kettle bell would be
one that had like a rubber skin around
that was super durable, but it was like a
rubber, like a runway, a year and a half.
And then you gotta get you gotta.
You gotta get it comes with cranes
that you put on at once a month.
You got to take care of it. Shit. So
the new howler monkeys, a 18 pounds,
so it's 18 pounds.
There's a 36 pound champ,
54 pound Orangutang and 72 pound gorilla.
They're all done in these
things called poons,
which are a Russian series of measurement,
which thank God they
don't only use anymore.
I used to just say like one pooed two
pood and everybody's like, what the fuck?
I got to Google a pooed the gorillas,
the motherfucker though, that's the,
that's the one I use. You use the group
food 72 pounds. Yeah, it's awesome.
I use that for alternating cleans son.
Was that the one that you
posted a photo of? Yes or no?
That was one of my regular ones.
You take a cha hot chicks head and
open up the mouth. Cool. I have, uh,
two different gyms at my
house, the gym and the, uh,
the house with the weights is I just a
regular kettlebells and then one in the
garage with the MMA equipment.
That's all the gorilla ones.
They were talking about you, uh, on
Opie and Anthony on the way over here.
I was listening about you
doing kettle bells today.
Why were you talking
about me doing get them?
But I know just how sexy that photo was.
Put out some kind of kettle bell.
All right.
You're doing a gun
talking about [inaudible].
I smoke too much. I told you guys no,
you're fine. You're fine too. Don't panic.
I told you, use the offer code. Rogan, the
code, Bonus Code, whatever it is, Rogan,
Rga and save 10% any and all supplements.
All right.
We love the fuck out of here and
we're ready to start this shit.
Good googly Mowgli. Eddie
Bravo. Good googly Mooglie.
What does that mean? That's a Joey d is
this thing now everybody's saying it.
If people say it all the time when you
see something fucking crazy, he goes,
good googly Mowgli
duck.
I haven't heard that yet. That must be
brand now. It's a fairly recent one.
A Joey's been doing it for the past.
I'm sure it's an old saying like you
remember the Sasquatch, Hannah hat store.
He went off about the weed. What?
Hannah? We, we didn't know what the fuck
that meant. I bet. Good
googly Mowgli's like that.
It's probably something that dude's used
to say to each other. I remember that.
You remember good googly Mowgli?
I think they used to say going in
cartoons a lot, actually like old.
Now that you're saying that, I kind of
remember that. Googley can. Where did,
okay, let's Google the origin
of good googly Moodley.
You think that would, uh,
possibly everything comes up, man.
Yeah, right. Okay. Let's
say the origin of good,
good blue moon. Yup. Urban Dictionary.
Wow. Anywhere for awhile. What are
you, what are you doing currently?
What are you play on the commercial?
It has it on there. It's old.
They're not going anywhere
for awhile. Great. Currently
Mister Magoo would say something
like that. Yeah, I remember my,
I think my grandfather used to say it
or something or it used to be in the old
looney tunes or,
well,
it's in the urban dictionary and if
phrase used when a real thick female walks
by and you want to say,
damn,
that's like an update.
They're basically co-opted it.
They hijacked it. Great. Googly movie
orange.
How long is it going to take for Jelly?
D has to be like an alias to act
or just a tremendous phenomenon.
Yeah,
exactly right.
Here's the origin. Here's
the origin. Great Google,
good googly mcgleesy and Frank
Zappa's Song Nanak rubs it.
The song was released in 1974 the term
is now used as an utterance of great
surprise.
Oh Wow.
I like the wonder years definition
better. Yeah. Well that's, it works today.
That's the urban dictionary.
So you see a girl. That's true. You can
say something out loud. Good. And Yeah,
you could, and it's not offensive. How
could a girl get pissed off at that?
Especially if you're not looking
at her. Yeah. You know what?
A [inaudible] hanging out with a couple
of Brazilian guys and there's one
Brazilian guy that he says
what his pickup line was.
My gotch like you would just go,
my God,
that works in Brazil. Great.
But not in the states.
Oh my God.
That's all you need to Brazil.
That's all. Yeah, exactly. You just
grab them and you just take them.
Girls are used to that shit.
What is it about Brazil that's there's
way more girls in those countries?
Like Brazil and Argentina are very similar
and that there's way more girls than
there has guys. In the beginning when
we first started training Jujitsu,
the Machados,
we hear all these stories about Brazil
and we all thought Jujitsu was his
biggest soccer in Brazil based on what
they were telling us. And they'd say, man,
when you go to Brazil
at 11 girls fabric guys,
grant humble and what I what?
So these Americans
and should dudes it Carlos Machado's
guys, all the Texas guys, we gotta go,
we gotta go to Brazil.
So in 2000 we went to check it all out.
And uh, it's true, there is a,
you just see that there's more girls
like statistically it's gotta be,
cause you see it and you even
see it more in Argentina,
I was in Argentina three years ago and
you see just droves and gangs of girls
just all together.
But they react different to the situation
in Argentina and Brazil. In Brazil,
it's, it's a lot easier to
make moves on checks in Brazil,
but in Argentina it backfired.
So girls are in Argentina there,
they're just like, they don't trust
dudes. At all cause dudes can,
can easily have multiple girlfriends
and prostitution is totally legal.
So girls in Argentina pissed off and
they're like, why should I trust you?
You're going to definitely have other
girlfriends and, and if I pissed you off,
you're going to go right
to the whorehouses proved
to me that you, you know,
so they're pissed off the girls. That's,
that's my experience in Argentina.
That's the one argument,
I mean against the
prostitution is that it forces,
it allows rather guys to not
be forced into relationship.
Like how do you develop
meaningful relationships and
have children and all that
jazz. There's legalized
prostitution everywhere because
if you've got a couple of
bucks and someone starts talking Shit,
you just go, I'm crying. You know,
like you start going, I don't
need this. I don't need,
I don't need someone in my life
yelling at me just so I can get my sex.
I could just go right over there. The guy
that was taking us around in Argentina,
we had a guide.
He said that it's very typical that
you go out on a date with a chick.
You're just, you know, you
try to civilians, you try
and say, well, you know,
the, the whore houses are
always going to be there.
So he said he would just take a girl to
a club and need to be dancing and if you
know,
he'd start putting his hands on,
on the dance floor and trying to grab
her ass. And if she wasn't intuitive,
she didn't respond.
He would just say,
I'm going to the bathroom and just go
right out and jump in a cab and go right
to the whorehouse he had
no patience is telling us.
So that's where the girls are so
pissed because girls are used to that.
Girls are used to guys just saying,
okay, I'm out. You know? Yeah.
They don't have to take any,
they don't have to beg basically.
What does that do to a culture that's
very strange when you stop and think about
it, you know, because I'm,
I'm a person that believes totally
and personal freedom and I don't think
there's anything wrong with someone
being a prostitute if they want to be a
prostitute.
I think if you were working at Denny's
serving people food for fucking $3 an
hour, or someone says, Hey, you're
getting a hundred bucks an hour,
you could fuck a bunch of Nice guys.
You know why not? Why not do that?
I'm not saying that it should
be something that people pursue,
but why is it okay to give someone a hug?
Why is it okay to give someone a massage
and it's not okay to suck their deck?
Why is they have a great point?
Hey, you can pay for a massage.
Someone who doesn't want to touch you,
rubs on you for an hour and a half,
but you,
you're me that the
first of all,
we both know there are crazy girls out
there that would probably love to blow a
bunch of guys all day. They exist. They do
porn. Yeah. I don't know why they exist,
but they exist. You could say
they exist because of the abuse.
He could say they exist
because of childhood neglect.
That's possible. I agree.
But they exist.
And it's not like you're supporting that
market by creating whorehouses like the
market that,
that those people are going to be there
no matter what you do unless you clean
up society. So you're always gonna have
people that are off the rails. Why not?
That's the,
is that the big one disease,
because you have to control the disease
with a back massage or not getting
fucking aids. Well, I,
you know what crazy that you would
think out of all the people on the,
on the planet,
hookers would be the first to get aids
and they're not really getting aids.
Isn't that crazy?
I don't know if anybody's really
checking on hookers going like, hey,
how you doing? Well, you
know, you listened to that
guy you had on your podcast,
dude.
Duisburg he said in Brazil,
virtually none of the hookers have aids.
I don't know if he's going down
there with the fucking pap smear.
That motherfucker, I don't know
about Duisburg man. I do not know.
Um,
I found his,
the conversation with him to be absolutely
fascinating and very confusing. And I,
you know, use the phrase, uh, I hate it
when I'm too dumb to know who is stupid.
You know,
I don't know if this one guy has it
nailed and all these other doctors are out
of their mind and they were all
chasing a disease. It doesn't exist.
That doesn't make enough sense to me.
It doesn't make enough sense when this
guy starts talking about HIV and that HIV
doesn't cause aids,
but yet everyone else thinks does like
this is like serious peer reviewed
scientists that think it does. So
that's just confuses the shit out of me.
He makes a lot of sense though.
It makes a lot of sense.
That's what even break it down were
another debate him and Callen had,
I mean it seemed at the very end of that
it seemed like as a skeptical is Brian
is it seemed like at the very
end based on your podcasts,
it sounded like he was starting to
believe that it's a bad situation.
First of all, it's unfair because
Brian is not a geneticist. He has no,
no engineering background or no
bio a engineering background.
He has no idea what
Duisburg does for a living.
Like his concept of like how it all
works is so rudimentary. It's like,
so for him to debate a guy like that,
it's not fair.
He shouldn't have been doing it. Um, I,
I wanted to have him on because he's a
smart dude and you should get something
to, yeah, I tried. Nobody wants to
do it. It's really hard. I hired,
one of the reasons why we started working
with Matt stags is that very reason to
be able to get guests like that,
to be able to get, um, you know,
use a publicist to reach out and let
someone know that this is a legitimate
showed we're trying to get to the bottom
of something. No one wanted to touch it.
No one will.
One guy wanted to touch it and then he
had all this backlash apparently from his
peers. People don't want
you even debating Duesberg.
They think that it's almost like
debating a holocaust denier. You know,
debating someone, uh, know who,
who believes really dangerous shit.
And so they think that his, what
his work has done, it's killed many,
many people. I don't buy that
though. My problem with, I don't buy,
I think the truth is somewhere in the
middle, but these, these people that say,
you know, doozer burgers responsible
for all these people in Africa,
not taking their medication and all dying.
His points about Africa
were really fascinating.
He was talking about how in Africa they
say that everyone has aids but they're
not testing for HIV.
They're,
they're assuming these people have aids
because their immune system is trounced,
but you're also dealing with people that
are exposed to a wide variety of other
disorders and diseases and
they have terrible, terrible,
terrible nutrition and it's,
these people were not getting proper
healthcare and when you see they're sick,
if they have aids in quote,
at least you know that that qualifies
for them to have funds for them to get
funding. If you're dealing with
an AIDS epidemic, you get money,
you get money from charities for an aids
epidemic, you don't get money. You know,
based on the fact that
people aren't eating right,
you don't get money based on the fact
that immune system sucks because they're
in a fucking tropical jungle. I
talked to this disease expert, um,
when I was doing that Scifi show and
he said that people live in jungles,
like people who live in
tropical environments. On
100% of them have diseases,
hundred percent. He's like,
they've all got something. He goes,
everyone has something. And I was like,
what do you mean like something he's like,
there's all sorts of different diseases.
There's under the undiagnosed diseases,
there's ailments and they just live with,
there's parasites that get in their
system. It's just, it just, they get it.
That's like the toxoplasma thing
that we talked about. Yeah.
That's why it's like that.
That kind of environment.
How does it chick that lives in the Amazon
jungle get into a river and not have
vaginal parasites?
How is that possible?
They got to be covered
with vaginal parasites.
That must be a problem in the jail.
We already have them from drinking water.
Does it make their pussy feel better?
No.
It gives you a buck and bumpy and
Dick Dick Parasites pick leeches,
little tiny microscopic ones that dude's
pull out on their own level and every
time they pull it out, it's not checking
the town. You're not joking around, man.
There must be. I'm just saying
there must be no listen man.
When dudes pissed in the Amazon,
they have to cover their dick
used to piss into your hand.
You gotta cover your Dick Because
fish will swim up your urethra tape.
Worms coming out of your penis hole.
That's not bullshit though.
They find your urine and they swim up
river into your deck and then they,
you have to cut them out.
Why do they need, isn't it?
Wouldn't it be easier if
they weren't pissing? Dude,
the world is trying to kill you.
No,
but if you weren't pissing
and young little lagoon,
isn't it easier but can't find the
hole and it follows the river of pis,
swims up the river.
It's evolved.
Like follow the river like
salmon swim up to your mind to,
I used to have a jury about that.
I used to have a joke about that.
I did know there was a
real disease that did that.
I used to joke about it being at a strip
club and peeing really hard cause I was
scared that the vd from the toilet was
going to swim up river and my Dick.
That's hilarious.
But I didn't know that they really like
got something actually does that free.
We'd Rogan right there.
It is 99 Rogan.
There's a rat actually fish that
does that. Like a parasite cleanse.
A call to your deck. Okay, let's find out.
Swims and Amazon chicks,
which it Amazon fish swims in music.
You know the kind of condom you
would need? You would need a fucking,
NASA would have to make that condom
made out of Levi's and have to be one of
those condoms that are actual shorts too.
It's one piece.
They're like booty shorts
and a condom all in one. Oh,
this thing is got the tape
that it'd be too hard.
It's called the Ken
Guru. The candy room, uh,
is a toothpick fish or vampire fish.
A species of parasitic freshwater catfish.
Ah,
native to the Amazon basin where
it's found in countries like Bolivia,
Brazil, Columbia, Ecuador,
and Peru. Jesus Christ. Oh,
just swims.
Wow.
The smaller species are known for a
tendency to Nva alleged tendency to invade
parasites and parasites,
the human urethra. However,
despite ethnological reports dating
back to the late 19th century,
the first documented case of the removal
of the candy row from a human urethra
did not occur until 1997 and even
that incident has remained a matter of
controversy. Huh. So it might be bullshit.
Did they might have anal catfish.
Well, look at that thing. How's that
going to get into tip of your Dick?
Unless you want it to my shifts. That
could definitely get into vaginas. Yeah.
Yeah. Of girls will be in there. Fucking
Amazon Shit. Wow. This is weird. Okay,
so this might totally be bullshit.
Historical accounts.
Earliest published reports of this can
dirus attacking a human host comes from
the German biologist,
CFP von [inaudible] in 1829
who never actually observed it,
but rather was told about it
by the natives of the area,
including that man would tie a ligature
around their penis going into the river.
Then this are happening.
You know what that meant?
That meant dude's where they
had cock rings on and they
got busted and then like,
no, no, no. There's a fish
to fry up your Dick. Dude,
you sound like a prophetic to take a
trip into the Amazon and one dude's all
into bang and Amazon chicks in here. Like,
Dude, look at this man. No, it's bullshit.
I totally believe it. It makes
sense. Yeah. All that kind of does,
but it seems like there was only one
case where one was pulled out of a dude's
Dick.
Maybe they just,
they're just comfortable with
them and they just live with them.
They just know him.
Well, let's go Google up.
Can dirus removed from deck is probably
a kind of put it in his dick. Yeah,
that's what they're saying.
That's what they're saying.
They're saying Amazon
girl vaginal parasite.
Ooh,
here's,
here's something on aol.com about an
eel that swam up somebody's penis and it
had to be surgically removed. Okay, well
hold on a second. There's a fucking,
there's a penis removal video. Yeah, Dude.
Oh my God. Go to this. Can
Dro Penis removal operation.
Oh No. Yes, yes, yes. Get to that.
Can D or a c a n D I r u
penis removal operation.
Good googly Moodley is all I have to say.
This is fucking crazy,
man.
This is fucking crazy.
Did you get it?
Hmm?
Click on this. Where do you see this
shit? They got one of them scopes,
so they're going down this
guy. Look, he's got off fish.
He's got a little fish camped
out. Inside is packer. Oh my God.
You imagine in your fucking pissle
this guy. Oh my God. It's got eyes.
It's a fucking fish. Jesus Christ.
Oh, there's a fish in this guy's Dick.
This is madness.
Okay.
This is fucking madness.
This is a real thing.
This fish really does swim in your Dick
and you got to send this dude in there
with a vacuum cleaner,
a vacuum cleaner with a camera in the
end of it to suck it out of there.
And then the fish is
swimming away from your deck.
Is this in the Amazon or what it says,
what does this happen?
Um,
yes,
it said it lodged in the penis of Silvio
Barbosa after urinating in the air.
Amazon River, tributary, doctor and new,
our Ahmad removes the Kundera
fish in a two hour operation.
Dude, he's got to keep going in there.
Look at how many there are in there.
Oh my God. Oh my God. He's,
it's like his ass is packed with Dick's,
but it's not.
It's this penis Packwood fish.
Couldn't you just like put a poisoning,
killed them all, and then
would kill you dick. Too stupid
and had to be something I would
inject poison in your Dick.
What did it breaks your Dick?
You got to let the bad man with the
vacuum cleaner go in there and do his
business. How did they deal with
it before doctors? They didn't.
They would just die.
They just died.
They just have a official living in
that Dick, you're not getting it out.
What are you going to do? You're going
to send a fucking fish hook in there.
Maybe a Sharman could do something,
put it a little baby cash flow on. It.
Blows some that would
probably want a WASC a dust on
this last year, uh, this
last, um, uh, weekends, UFC,
you know, who'd see? Do you know
who is who? Yeah, he, the um, uh,
he's a AK striking coach.
No, you know that guy.
He's a bad ass striking coach
and it dies or something.
That's Javier Mendez. Yeah. He, he
did some stuff with them to his, um,
I forget his last name, but anyway, he uh,
does dude got k owed and he
was like singing a song forum.
Okay.
Was it as fighters? No, it was the other
day. Who's taking care of, you know,
corners and Chet and so, you know how
they have a bunch of different, um,
guys who are trainers or,
or a commission,
guys who washing guys and who are, you
know, taking care of various things.
Like cut man and stuff like that.
And they run in and take care
of corners doing various things.
So they're not that night. He wasn't part
of that wasn't with that guy. Exactly.
So the, um, I don't know, you know,
it was exact a business he was doing
there anyway when the dude was out,
he was singing them when the Iowasca
song and I, and I, and I, you know,
I talked to him about it and he's like,
he's in the place of the dreams. You know,
I tried to make them comfortable
comfort while he was there,
at least serious about it. It's pretty,
pretty intense. You know, he's a,
he's an Iowaska Shaman, so he'll, he do,
he does like ceremonies and shit. Damn.
Yeah. Yeah. So it was, it was
pretty cool. How often do you see,
when we see him all the time,
tell him I'm interested in
doing a ceremony with him.
He'll do it. Yeah, I'm down.
We'll come down, we'll bring them
down to a list or wants to do this.
I'm not doing that with him,
you know, too much
troubles. Troubles really
MMA fighter. He's like, I like
dean. He's a good dude, man.
Because he retired from MMA.
I don't know, but I was with him
all weekend in China for Abu Dhabi.
Did he can be, he did. How
did he do? He did great.
He had four or five heel hooks.
He didn't win the gold medal in anything,
but he may have gotten
third in his division.
Grappler, Dude's this year. Holy Shit.
China stinks.
And if I never go back there again,
I mean it stinks.
Like literally like my bathroom
and my hotel stunk. Like the sewer.
It was like the water, they turn off the
water and then they turn it on. But uh,
the people are beautiful in China.
They're beautiful,
but they just have a problem in Beijing
with their sewers. Man. It's just, whew.
You walk down the street and every block
and like, whoa, Jesus, what's your,
just too many people, someone die
or does someone take a shit? Um,
I don't know if it's that it's just old,
but Abu Dhabi was amazing.
The whole, the tournament. Jesus
Christ, I was so much. So, I mean, uh,
uh, you know, Amir alum,
one of my brown boats thought
in the heavyweight division
and he trained his ass
off man.
He was ready,
he was on fire and we get to an unknown
in the first round. So we're thinking,
awesome. We should beat this guy. We
didn't, his last name was dop, Jared. Dot.
We thought, okay, we should
be able to beat this guy this,
because he could easily had
cyborg in the first round. Right?
You could easily have [inaudible] on the
first round. That would have been, fuck,
okay, good luck. You know? But people
don't understand. There's a bunch of
Cyborg. You only heard of a Cyborg.
The woman fighter Cyborg turns out
her ex husband is an MMA fighter named
Cyborg,
but there's a Roberto I brew. Is
that how you say? Yeah, it bad ass.
She won the absolute,
he's amazing.
This guy impressed the shit out of me.
He's so big.
He's a fucking ox buddy.
Moves like a gazelle dude.
It was incredible. There's a couple of
passes that he did just blew my mind.
I'm like running it and I'm on the plane
on the way back going over that pass,
like I can't forget that pass.
I got to analyze it.
It was amazing tech that was at
least 10 different techniques, right?
Logged it in my brain. I got to go back
and check that one out. Like, yeah.
Cabrina the guy who wanted
all into lightweight,
he finally beat half a Mendez man,
have Amanda's one the last two years.
He's virtually indestructible.
Uh, and Cabrina.
We're in the finals again and Cabrina
one that he pulled it out a judge's
decision at the end. They couldn't
sport a score. Any points on the chart,
they just canceled
about those though.
Those are weird when the judges make a
score and I don't have a real problem
with that.
Well, the one thing I love about
Abu Dhabi is the chic is he's,
I mean,
he's such a bad ass.
The sheet just decides to put together
the Best Jujitsu tournament on the plan.
He just makes it happen. He
pays for it. It's all all,
all over the world. One year.
It's an Sao Paulo, one years in
Barcelona, it's an La to China.
It's amazing. The sheik just throws
down and he makes it happen. And he,
he created the rules,
Eh,
the format based on what he thought would
be best for the entertainment value.
So he's down to evolve over
the years. He's tweaked
stuff. He's like the Japanese,
the Japanese and pride. As soon as they
recognize a problem, the fucking chain.
True people have no idea what
we're talking about. The, uh,
Abu Dhabi is Abu Dhabi combat
championships, right? Combo club.
They have the biggest Jujitsu,
no Geek Jujitsu tournament in the world.
They have this huge thing
and it's put together by,
and he sees them talk noon. Yeah. He, uh,
is also part owner of the UFC and
he's a black belt in Jujitsu is a huge
[inaudible] fan.
So you put together like this enormous
grappling competition that's the most
prestigious grappling,
a event in the world.
And so Eddie was just there
in China with war fighters.
So how did he do it again?
Let's do it
well, well, let me finish what I
was talking about. The chic is a,
we're talking about, we're getting to the
format, the rules. Yeah. So, you know,
one of the coolest thing that he
changed was the same day, Wayne.
He changed that shit.
And not only is it because I generally,
especially in MMA and pro MMA,
you weigh in officially the day before
and then you have 24 hours to recover.
So that's huge in deciding what weight
category you're going to compete in and
how you're going to lose the weight.
How are you going? It's massive.
If you have to do a same day, way
in, Ooh, shit, everything changes.
Now you can't have that crazy diabolical
cut that you're, you're used to.
Now it's a little different.
And the IBJ I've changed it to,
they may get you weigh in right before
you step the mat and if you way,
uh, even a pound over, boom, you're
gone. So Abu Dhabi, the sheik,
he, he'd add, added did the same thing
you do. Not only is it same day wins,
but you've got to weigh in that you've
got to win the day before the day of and
the next day if you make it to
the third, uh, the third round,
you have to keep weighing in.
It's gonna say,
cause it seems kind of dangerous if you
just did it right before you went and
got some guys would still probably
push themselves too. Yeah.
What I mean it's risky because you,
you see these high level grapplers every
now and then you see them gas and they
try to cut too much weight and you
don't have that much time to recover.
So if you're going to do a same day way
in, especially Matt Sideway and man,
you just got to get in the best shape
of your life and figure out what weight
that is and you really,
you really can't cut really,
or you're going to pay for it.
You're going to gas out.
And some people still take the
chance to though. But with the rules,
the sheik decided the best thing to
do to ensure action most of the time,
because no matter how you put
together the rules, you're going to,
not every match is going to be exciting.
You have to accept that,
but you're always looking to make,
make the majority are just striving
for the majority of the matches to be
exciting. So in Abu Dhabi,
every tournament does shit
different. But and Abu Dhabi,
they're 10 minute matches,
the finals or 20 minute matches.
But in these 10 minute matches, the first
five minutes, there's no points at all.
They don't count anything.
And the second five minutes,
that's when the points started. And
if you pull guard, you lose a point.
So that,
that's huge when strategizing for a fight.
Because when you're competing in this,
explain to people why the first
five minutes, there's no point.
So that was something that was instilled.
Yeah,
that was instilled so that if there's
no points you'd be a fighter's would,
would take more chances.
Because generally if there's
points counting all the time,
you don't want to take any chances.
One wrong slip dudes up two points.
Now he's up,
he's just going to hold.
He doesn't really think
about the submission.
He's just trying to get to the next round.
So it changes the dynamics of your
strategy and and how it, how it plays out.
So the sheik thought, okay, let's, let's,
let's try to shake it up
first five minutes, no points.
So the fighters will take more chances
and that turns into entertainment for the
viewer.
So that happens sometimes with
some fighters and Jacques Machado,
he took advantage of that.
He went out there,
pulled guard and got the party rolling.
He's like, okay, I'm going to sit down.
You get on top,
let's go.
I'm not going to spend five minutes trying
to take you down. I'm not a wrestler.
You wrestles your whole life. Let's
just get the party started. I'll get,
I'll let you get on top.
I'll kick the ball off to let you,
I'll let you receive first. How
about that? That's all that is.
So in the first round guys will do that.
They're like,
I'm not going to spend all my
energy trying to take a deep down.
It's not a wrestling competition.
So they sit down,
the problem is in the second half of
the match, if you decide to sit down,
you lose a point.
So the ref goes points at five minutes.
So wherever you're at the next
transition that, uh, you know, uh,
like if you already have the guys
back at that five minute mark,
they don't give you the points. You have
to lose the back and then get it back.
So a lot of weird stuff that I didn't
understand, but, but gem, but again,
the point of this weird, uh,
format is to make it better.
So the chic is always
trying to make it better.
And the one thing I'm pretty
sure he's going to, he's,
he's got to change that.
Uh,
losing a point if you pull guard, cause
that changes a lot. We saw a lot of,
not a lot, but a couple of the finals
were both Jujitsu guys, worldclass,
Jujitsu guys. I Cabrina and Hoffa,
some of the two best guys in the world.
Very good at submissions.
Amazing at passing. Unbelievable.
Beautiful Jujitsu.
Well you hadn't,
and their match is nobody wanted to pull
guard cause in that in the finals you
lose a point right away. They don't
give you, it's not the first half.
No point in that really good. Those
come from God just having shitty guards.
It comes from people not realizing
how dangerous a guard is.
If a guys a real bad motherfucker
with it. Yeah. And we saw that too.
One of the competitors came in. He's a
22 year old kid. Him and his brother,
real famous.
They just got their black belts there.
The meow brothers are like
Machita like half Japanese,
half Brazilian from Brazil,
like the kitty cat.
But it's like Sao Paolo meow
meow meow cat. It could be,
but it's spelled I think am I,
why does she get Brian to design a shirt?
Totally.
Well these guys,
all they do is pull guard and play
della haven spiral guard relentlessly.
They don't stop. That's all
they do. They're relentless.
They have an infinite amount of
cardio and that's, that's his style.
He sits on his zero wrestling. So
that's why he lost, he lost because Bam.
So what ends up happening
with this rule set,
which was aimed at making
it more entertaining, but
what's happening now? Um,
and I'm sure the sheikhs going to see
this because everyone's talking about it
on the Internet. I'm not the
only one. Everyone's talking,
everyone as Deborah watching, everyone
came to the same conclusion and like, oh,
there's a problem here.
We've got a problem.
The chic is one of those
guys that will fix it and he,
and he's got to fix it because the problem
was we had co Breena and Hoffa in the
finals and they never,
they never try.
They just tried to take each other down
and they couldn't because they're not
wrestlers. The wrestling's decent,
you know, but, uh, according to,
due to no wrestling,
like due to wrestled in college,
they'll say they're at like a
high school state champion level,
you know, not d one, all
American Johnny Hendricks level,
whole different animal.
So we ended up getting is 20 minutes
of two dudes who have okay wrestling,
you know like d five rustling going at
it and we don't see any Jujitsu cause no
one want to anyone. They don't
want to pull guard. Oh yeah, yeah.
It's way easier to not get taken
down than to take someone down.
It's way easier.
Like if your whole focus is,
I'm not going to get taken down
and you're going to check me down.
Even if you wrestled in college and I
didn't wrestle him cause it's still gonna
be hard for you to,
of course I have to work on it.
But you can get that take down defense
a lot quicker than you can turn.
Exactly. Exactly. I take down ability,
man, that takes a no, no long time.
It's sprawling can come easier.
So what you end up having
as two dudes that uh,
were wrestling for a very long time,
they got to the ground briefly a couple
times and they went to double overtime,
triple overtime when Friday
at the very end, zero, zero.
The rough makes the decision and gave
it to Cabrina. So how does that work?
How can I make a decision like that?
That's what the initial,
that's how we got started off.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
I don't buy that. The how is that
going to walk away with a win? I mean,
I understand that they were,
you know,
they're the elite of the elite
and to have the best of the world,
I guess someone has to win, but that
doesn't make any sense to me. Yeah.
The rules need revamping and I'm quite
positive that the sheik is going to take
that because what you end up having, if
you don't lose a point for pulling guard,
it's, you know, losing a point for
pulling guard. It's like this. I,
I use a football analogy when I'm
trying to explain Jujitsu to someone who
doesn't know anything about Jujitsu.
I do you understand that the rules
of football and the strategy and most
Americans do,
so it's just like football.
There's generally a guy has
a ball and that the team has,
has the ball and they're marching down
the field and then a team is defending.
Try not to let them march down the field.
Same thing.
Guy On top in Jujitsu is
trying to march down the field.
Gone bottom is playing defense.
He the guy on defense
can score but it's not a,
it's a lot easier to score when you're
on top and you can use your weight cause
you have, it's like you have
the ball, you're scoring,
but the defensive football team can
intercept and run back for a touchdown.
They can score.
Some teams are very high so but it's rare.
Same thing with the bottom.
It's rare that there's guys that
can score a lot off their back,
but generally you want to be on top, you
want to have the ball. If you're on top,
you're in someone's open guard.
It's like you're on the 20 yard line.
You get on to top half,
you're like at the 50 yard line,
you pass the side control.
You can score from side control,
but it's a lot easier if
you score from the back.
So I controls like the 35 yard line.
The amount is like the 20 yard line.
Now you're in the red zone.
And if you get the dude's back first
and go on the 10 that's basically,
it's the same thing.
You're marching down the field.
You're getting into scoring position.
Yes. You can score from midfield.
You know you could score from top half.
You could throw a guillotine,
you can throw Darcy's,
but it's easier when you're on their back.
It's easier when you're right there.
Hundred 10 yard line, so in football,
the way they start the game as
the ref flips a coin, someone,
one of the teams picks
heads or tails and a,
I think it's the visiting
team and then if it's heads,
whoever wins the coin toss gets to
decide who receives and who kicks off.
Generally a large percentage of the
time. If you win the coin toss, you say,
we're going to receive and
you're going to kick off.
We're going to be on offense first.
You're going to be on defense first.
I'm going to be on top and you're open
guard. You're going to be on the bottom.
You flip a coin, you have to choose. Fuck.
Yeah. Generally I would do, I would say,
wait a minute. Wait, wait, wait.
So you're saying that you should do a
match where you flip a coin to say no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. What I'm saying
is what I'm saying is, so, uh,
sometimes a team will choose
to kick off and not receive.
That's kind of like if we're
going to grapple and I sit down,
I chose to play defense first.
That's what a guard pooler.
If it doesn't happen that often,
so it's penalizing someone one point for
sitting on their butt for letting the
guy get on top.
He's working to get on top of you.
Worked very hard on his wrestling
to get on top of the dude is saying,
I'm kicking off to you. You receive, I'm
going to let you go first. That's like a,
like a team saying we're going to kick
off to you and losing three points for
it. Like you, you are already giving
them an advantage. You're going to lose,
lose the advantage and points
doesn't make any sense.
You understand what I'm saying?
Dude.
See I could see if so say
if they don't have points,
you know they don't score
points, you know, um, with
their, their idea of advantage.
Maybe you could say you could give someone
an advantage if a guy pulled guard.
It's still a point cause
she said it went like that.
If you give an advantage is still one
zero zero with the the guy who has the
advantage of [inaudible] algae
actually really it should be,
it shouldn't be laughing.
It should be like this and she
that'd be submission only. That's it.
And you have overtime rounds and I
could explain that if you want here,
but generally of submission
only, no points, no advantages.
It's all about who gets the submission.
The whole goal is to get some mission
because in a lot of that was epic matches.
There's incredible athletes.
I have respect for all of them.
But when you're under this rule set you,
there's a lot of times in these matches
where the submission wasn't even a
thought. Just the w there were matches
where there's like three minutes left.
Guys sat on his ass, he loses
a point. Now I'm on top.
I want to win that money at the end
cause the winner of each division wins
$10,000.
He's the guy on top automatically
is going to be very cautious,
reserved and not uh,
be aggressive and definitely
not even consider a submission.
It's all about the w.
So that changes the entertainment value.
And for me that's the most important.
Do you think that it should
be just submission only?
It either submission only or you really,
really break down a point system for the
way it should be and this is the way it
should be. Like um, uh, in
Dean listers match against,
I forget who he lost it.
It was so many matches but he was down
on points and at the very end he puts,
I think it was you Alesis
he put them in a triangle.
He had them in a sense triangle at the
very end and he was down by two points,
maybe three, I'm not sure on
the points, but he was down,
it was 30 seconds.
Put them in a triangle
and in my eyes a triangle.
You should get more. Anything
since like a triangle, a figure,
if your legs are sense,
like you have a guy in a triangle,
doesn't mean he's going to tap.
A lot of times some guys escape.
But if it's totally sent, that guy was
in deep, deep trouble. If he escapes,
he got lucky.
So that that sense triangle
should represent weigh more
than a pass or a sweep.
That's just common sense.
So in my eyes,
if you want to score, keep
the scoring system and you,
you're, you're in love with,
you're going to commit to
the scoring system. Really
think about this, the score,
how you score this.
If a pass is three points.
If a sweep is two points,
uh, cinched Doris,
which people escape half the time.
But if you cinch it all the
way up and as a referee,
you should see if it's a near sub, if
it's a cinch. Darce sense triangle,
essential arm triangle, um,
uh, straightened out arm.
Like you straighten the guy's arm and
he escaped by the skin of his teeth.
You straightened out
his leg like a knee bar.
He escaped by the skin of his teeth.
You can see that I wouldn't count.
He'll hook and toehold attempts
cause then that would, you know,
they're so easy to just to jump on and
then it turns into just a bunch of, uh,
footsies. But if you, I
would count in my world,
I would count straightened the bars,
straight arm bars,
anything sensed any kind of,
um, that should be seven points.
Yeah, I agree with you. Sorry. I
think it should five something.
It should be like football. Yeah.
A pass. What is it now? It's one,
do you know anything? It is not in
Abu Dhabi. There's nothing watts.
It means nothing. Wait a minute. It
means not. That doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't mean anything.
So if a guy's ascension triangle,
that's not an near submission. That's
ridiculous. Wow. You have that.
Those rules are terrible.
She going to be,
it should be worth way more than a
sweep. Uh, yeah. Without a doubt. Yeah.
Sweeps. You know, people
recover from sweeps. Uh,
but if someone has you
that close to being tapped,
like a cinch to rear naked or something
along those lines, that's like a goal.
You make a touchdown, you
got out of it. But God damn,
I got to got to an incredibly dominant
position. Exactly. That should be,
and Naga is into evolution.
And so as grapplers quest grapplers
quests are doing selected super fights,
submission only.
So submission only is starting to spread.
The Gracie nationals is submission only.
Gracie world,
a submission only sub league up in the
Pacific northwest is a a submission only
Midwest submission challenge, which
are doing submission only, uh,
tournaments all over the Midwest.
It's growing, it's growing.
But if you're still committed to points,
like Nog is nugget,
they did change up and tweak the
point system. They are getting,
I think one point maybe
two for a near sub,
which they're on the right track.
You're on the whoever's running Naga,
you kip color,
you're definitely on the right track.
Let's turn it up a little bit more. Let's
make since Darcel ascension triangles,
seven points. It makes sense. That's like
a touchdown, a sweep as to, yeah, no,
I agree with you. We were both on
the same page. So besides that,
the the tournament, the Abu Dhabi ADCC
is the most prestigious on the planet.
If it wasn't for that tournament,
I wouldn't be sitting here.
That's for damn sure.
It just seems like those rules are just,
they need be revised. That's all.
Now tell me about kron Gracie.
That's what I was about to
tell you. You read my mind. No,
I'm looking at a video of him crying.
Gracie versus Gary Tonin.
Gary Tonkins,
a 21 year old dude who he
shocked everybody that match
was probably the greatest
grappling match of all time.
Gary tone it and crying.
Gracie Kron Gracie gets his arm,
straightens it out and look, he looks
like he's going to break it. Alert. Well,
you don't want what? You don't
want to tell about it. Trust me,
it doesn't even matter. He straightened
his arm out. He wouldn't have,
they kept rolling. Straighten
his arm. Everyone's going
nuts. He's real. He's real.
Everywhere he rolls, the Ar Chron is
right there. Every angle with the arm,
totally straight. It looked like it's
going to break. Everybody's going, aw,
it didn't,
he didn't just hold it and escape.
Do they a rolling all over the place
and that arm should have broke off to he
survived. He didn't tab gets
on top, takes Crohn's back,
puts him in the truck,
almost has Cronin, a twister.
Oh my grand spins out. He goes back
to the bag, puts an Anaconda on,
I'm Aka triangle body lock
on them has cron face down.
It looks over Hixon sitting there going,
oh damn.
And in the first match, that was
cron second match in its first match.
Crown demolished, uh, Andy
when I love you Andy Wang.
But he went right through him like in
30 seconds and Hixon didn't even move.
He's sitting there and he went right
through Andy Wang and Hixon Denny move.
And I was like, we're looking
at Hixson. I'm like, man,
that's way doper than getting all excited
him not doing anything like he expects
it. It's no big deal. You, you went right
through him. The best possible outcome.
Hixon didn't and make a move like Yoda
and I, I, I admired that. I'm like, wow,
that's deep right there. He's
not even happy. Not even a
smile, but in this match.
Hickson was like visibly shaking.
You could see him going,
what you he's watching and
where's this kid come out of?
I think he's from the east coast.
I'm not sure.
But he was on a that Bjj Kuma Tay thing
with a Heenan Cornelius who also did
amazing at Abu Dhabi. But
anyways, back to Guerin. Dude,
there's a minute left and at this point,
a minute and a half in Chron is doing
everything to try and escape your,
you were watching cron be defeated right
now. We're watching him be defeated.
After you almost had that dude's
arm like five different times.
[inaudible] struggling.
He can't get out.
Gary tones back defenses
or or back control is
professional assassin like chron
cannot get out, but by the skin of
his teeth, I have to see it again.
I don't know exactly I got,
but he got out, they stand up.
Hixon looks at him and goes,
you got one minute chron turns
around to take some down,
passes this guard, it takes a
while. He gets his back. Dude,
he's schools with two seconds left.
Gary taps.
Ah,
it was the craziest
submission match I've ever seen.
It's really fascinating watching crime
for people who don't know his dad is the
greatest Jujitsu guy of all time.
There's one guy that's always thought
of above all others in the world.
That Jujitsu, it ticks and grace.
You've got to have them on this podcast.
I would love to have a bond. It
would be easy. Would it be simple?
He lives in Brazil now. Doesn't mean
he's here, right? He, I dunno, I do.
You're right. You're right. I
don't know. I'll figure it out.
I'll get in touch with chronic.
I would fly him in first class.
Last time I saw Cron, um, it was at the,
when he fought Matt Hughes in La,
he, uh, he had that was like, oh,
seven or six. Yeah, he was a
young kid. He was really young.
There was right after I had,
uh,
I had dinner with Hixon once and I went
to his house and watch fights and he
broke down. What people are doing
wrong, dude, you know crazy. That is,
you went to Hickson's house,
hung out with them and watched fights,
broke down fights.
I remember you telling me this,
you were telling me he broke
down cause fade or at the,
at the moment was the Mr indestructable.
He was on top.
Everyone feared him and wanted
to fight him. Yeah. And he, yeah,
he broke down how to beat fade
on his mind, right? Oh yeah.
Oh he thought he could be fade or he
thinks he can beat anyone. He's a monster.
He's a scary dude when
you're, well, he's a master.
He's a true master Jujitsu and
he's got like that Samurai mindset.
A lot of people talk that Samurai
mindset. Yeah. That fucking dude lives it.
Like that is his mindset.
Yeah.
The Gracie family is very large
and there's a lot of sections,
a lot of Gracie clicks. There's the
Carlson side, there's the car, low side,
there's the helio side else
inside the house, inside. Uh,
and a lot of them hate each other.
A lot of them talk a lot
of crap on each other. Uh,
but Hixon man ever.
I don't know how many times I've heard
people say fuck that grace a grace.
He said like fuck that Gracie a Brazilian
or someone from the old school like
all the old school guys.
But they'll, they'll never,
they'll always say except Hickson,
they make,
they tell you except Texan like Alan
goes man Alan goals. There's little,
he has a lot of problems with
people but he makes it clear.
He goes but Hickson's awesome.
Excellent cause they all say it.
They all agree that although
there's no roles on video,
like now everyone has
their roles on video.
You could get them on youtube like
you catch Marcello's rose all day.
The greatest Jujitsu player ever.
But Hixon not too many roles
but everyone sets all like myth.
That's all legend but you got to believe
it cause everyone says the same thing.
Even David Camereo when he went down
there and David Cameron has a worldclass
black belt, he said he couldn't
do anything with Exim. Yeah.
Even Paulo Filo said that Paulo Filo went
down there and came back and was like
Jesus Christ,
he's a master.
He has been doing Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu community. Hixon is a god.
He's the best Gracie hands down.
So he had two sons and
one of them Hawkson, uh,
died a few years
back and he was already on his way
to being a bad ass Jujitsu player.
And his youngest son Cron over the last
couple of years has just become this
fucking p six and son.
And I remember when he was 12,
outside of a Jujitsu tournament,
some Ibj JF tournament and Domingo
State Hills here in California. Uh,
me and John Jock, my master John
Jacques Machado, we were outside.
He was basically giving me a sermon like
he always does and like everything that
comes out of his mouth as Gospel and
everything's perfect and he just has,
he's like a superhero and we're walking
outside and Crohn's 12 at this time and
he's messing around on a skateboard,
jumping up,
doing the score skateboard tricks.
And John John,
John Jack looks over at him and says,
that's the one right there. I tell you,
that is the one he's going to be
unstoppable. I'll never forget that.
He called it out and John's talk also,
he's called out a lot of people who you
thought were going to be legends and
John Jack said he doesn't have what it
takes. He's going to break. And I'm like,
no way. John Jock. He's like, watch him
break. He's going to break. And Damn,
he was right.
And there was a couple that he called
out that broke and they just disappeared
and see things. Sean
Shock. It really is Yoda.
And he, he uh, called out cron.
He knew it and [inaudible]
he's,
he is now in a select group that man,
I don't know if there's
more than three or four,
but he submitted everybody
in his weight division.
He tapped everybody out. And here's
another Hixon store. Oh, well,
John Jacques Machado was the first the
tap everyone out back in [inaudible] 99
or 2000,
one of those,
Abu Dhabi's 98 99 John Jacques
Machado shows up to Abu Dhabi.
He's the first superstar.
Back then everyone was having
trouble with the submissions.
A lot of the key champions.
We're having a little trouble submitting
dudes without the g and the wrestlers.
They didn't want to pass the
guard or someone, anybody,
but they could throw you around and you
ain't taking them down. So a lot of,
lot of boring matches in the early Abu
Dhabi and that's why the sheet kept
changing the rules, trying to, trying
to work, work it all out. But uh,
then the next God who
came and just submit it,
everybody in 2003 was Marcello Garcia.
He was the second coming of John Shock.
First I was John,
John Marcella Garcia and now, you know,
there've been other guys that have uh,
have a bunch of submissions and I would,
I be to high grace.
He's done a tremendous job.
So many good guys out there.
But as far as coming in and just
submitting everybody in your division,
maybe Haji did it too, I don't know.
But Kron Gracie did it last weekend.
He went through everybody and you know,
the Gary Tone and fight,
that was a close one, man. He
escaped by the skin of his teeth.
But that showed how awesome he is and,
and how we can come back.
And in the final, you know,
first we have Hickson, the first,
first couple of matches,
he's just real chill zen.
And then when he beat Gary Tone and
you see Hicks and jumping up chronos.
Yeah,
I'd never seen Hixon so happy he was
trying to get him from the or without
actually
he was trying to get the twister before
he even got the lockdown on the back leg.
He was like,
he was thinking about it early.
He was thinking about
putting like as yeah.
As the body triangles wrapped around them.
He's thinking of grabbing a snack.
Yeah. Yeah. Where's this kid Trina?
Gary Talon. And Look, I'm a t. O. N. O. N.
Do that transition where you took
Crohn's back is insane. And not only,
you know what Gary and did,
he ended up doing the absolute and the
first round he went against the butcher,
which whose who won the heavyweight
division who is considered the best new
heavyweight dude moves like
a panther blue Shasha is,
I think his name is Marco
Elmeda. Man. You know,
some of these Brazilians, I know them
by their nickname, but the real name is,
is uh, it's hard to remember sometimes,
but boot will Shasha he, he wins his head,
the heavyweight division. Now he
signs up for the absolute first round.
It's Gary Tonin who's 170 pounds against
Boucher who just won the heavy heavy
weight.
That's the worst possible drop.
The smallest guy gets the biggest guy
and you know what Boucher can tap him.
It was a good match,
which just I got all sorts of position
on him but Gary kept recovery and Gary
kept attacking and this will,
he loses that right on point but he
didn't get put put, put away. And um, uh,
the guy was talking about earlier,
Jared dop, the guy who beat him here,
he ended up beating your mirror. We
were like, fuck man, we got an unknown.
It was perfect. We should have
beat. This guy was a close match.
A Amir had his back for a
second but didn't get points.
He had them in a Kamora didn't get points
for any of that and the guy took him
down once it passes guard and I'm,
you're lost on points and,
and it was kind of a shocker. I was the
first round, like, damn, we, who is,
we got a guy, a guy that no one knows
that we should have beat him. Damn.
Then he gets a Vinnie Maga last,
the next round. Jared. Dot.
He Beats Vinny.
Whoa.
So then we're like thinking any lost Vinny
got beat by the guy that beat a Amir.
Why do you think that's because
Vinny, he's doing so much. I'm a man.
I'm just not doing, Vinny was
not in shape for this. Vinny, he,
he admitted it to me.
He didn't train very much at all.
He just couldn't turn it down.
You know?
I'm sure it had a lot to do with him
getting cut by the UFC and not really
fucked with his mind for awhile
and last fire was hard. Yeah.
Yeah. Knocked out like what's the first
punch that a homeboy through and he never
expected that he fought. Um,
uh, Australian gentlemen.
The fuck's his name? Uh, Anthony.
Yeah. Anthony [inaudible],
who's a black belt in Jujitsu.
And that's what a lot of people expected.
They thought it was going to be a,
a Jujitsu versus Jujitsu Bell.
And he caught Vinnie
like with the first one
he got, he gets cut. He's
in a depressive state.
He's not really training hard for
Abu Dhabi. And Jared dop beat him.
He's from Rafael Lovato is camp. He's
a purple belt. That's incredible. Yeah.
So he's just incredible specimen.
So he gets Cyborg next.
He gets Cyborg next and he is winning.
He's beating him all. He's gotta
do a survive for 30 more seconds.
He would have beat Amir Olam, the
top 10 planet heavyweight, uh,
Vinnie, Michael [inaudible] who won the
gold medal in the APIs absolute in 2011.
And then Cyborg. He was going
to be Cyborg. He wouldn't,
but at the very end, cyborg pulled it
off and he impressed the shit out of me.
And cyborg ended up winning. Uh, he
ended up getting third in his weight,
Boucher one, and in the absolute
Cyborg took it all. He beat Boucher,
shot in the finals. It was PR. I
mean, what did Cyborg catch him with?
He'd beat him on points. I'll catch
you if not, it's just points site.
So he was losing it until the
last few minutes of Jared.
Dot was beating him on points.
And then I forget how it went down again.
There was a 50 batches, but so all I
remember Cyborg came back at the very end.
The Gero dop couldn't hold up.
He had it,
he just could hold on it and Cyborg
pulled it out of his ass, got some points.
I think he took his back or
something, got some, some,
some good points and barely pulled
it off. He was, he's, I mean,
and then Jared dop did the absolute
and he beats his first guy and maybe a
second guy. Then he gets hurt. He
asked the bowel out his shoulder shirt.
He was gonna get a rematch with
Cyborg in the absolutes. But you know,
since he couldn't go,
Gary Tone in one 70 pounder
who'd lost against Boucher, who,
who gave him a gay a great match.
They call him and go, dude, you're in.
And he's like,
Oh shit.
So now he's going to get Cyborg
240 pounds of pure leopard.
You know what I mean? And like tiger
and he's built like a brick shit house.
Oh yeah.
It was videos of him training strength
and conditioning online pushing shit shit.
And you know what he Gary
tone and look great man.
He was given Cyborg fits. That is
going to be a superstar. My words. Yes.
Just remember Gary Tonin [inaudible]
that big and he's given, it must be,
how young is this kid? 21
strong shit. That's amazing.
Yeah. He's not even a big
guy. And I looked at the
video of him crying. He says,
Dude, looks at a normal size guy.
He's out of control and he plays his,
his best shit is a part of
the same style that I play.
Gary Teton and plays
a lot of prison guard.
I don't know if he calls a prison guard,
that's just what I named it. But it's,
it's like, uh, uh, a head
and arm from the bottom.
It's basically a Greco Roman
full guard game. That's what an,
I call it prison guard. There
was nothing brown belt. Yeah,
yeah. Crazy. Yeah. And Oh,
the way he got Crohn's back, the way
he got it was through prison guard.
And again, it's, it's not, uh,
something that I'm sure he names it,
but it's something that I named and
it's a head and arm from the top,
from the bottom, and you squeeze on it
and just shuck that arm that's caught, uh,
in between your arm.
Just shuck it over your head.
You've got to get really good at that.
And you get, you can go right to the back
or you could transition to swim,
move to spiderweb,
or if you can't shut
the arm over your head,
you could transition right
into rubber guard beautifully.
Or You could put the Pharcyde
butterflying in and get some sweeps.
So it's a very, very strong
position. The actual position, uh,
the whole style I call prison guard,
but the actual positions called homie
control and homey control is the mission
control of prison guards. So I play
it all the time, all the time. And,
uh, watching Gary Tonin go to it
over and over, did it to Cyborg.
He would decide it was too big.
It didn't really work on him.
And then he did it on a Bouchet shock.
He kept trying. I'm like, I dunno,
prison guard is going to work on a guy
that has a hundred pounds on you or
something. But, uh, he kept going
to it. So I look out for Gary Tonin.
Yeah. It sounds like kids
a beast. I love that.
I love with all these new dudes are
just coming up out of nowhere. Yeah.
That's one of the cool things about
Jujitsu is that there's so many guys out
there practicing it now.
Yeah. I think someone,
it's about time for
someone to put it on TV.
I think one of these days they're going
to figure out a format or the guys are
going to get talented enough or scary
enough where you're going to be able to
put it on TV. And it'll be something
that I think about that all the time.
And I've had a invest, I've have a show
that, uh, it's, it's a concept. Uh,
we had financial backers that were
interested and then they back out.
We had a couple of other more than we're
interested in, they back out there,
I'm not sure, but the whole goal of mine
with this show is a 16 man tournament.
The whole goal is entertainment value
and everything is designed to score.
It's a,
it's a submission only format.
There's a few different ways
you can go with submission only,
but the way everything in my mind was
all designed to create urgency for this
submission. Like the,
the, like for example,
the ultimate urgency would be you do a
submission only match between two guys
and the winner gets $1 billion.
The loser gets nothing.
You imagined urgency of that
and how exciting that would be.
Obviously you don't really mean $1
billion, but I'm just saying I'm just,
that's an example. If you could give
them a billion, that'd be great.
But let's say realistically in 50 years,
a hundred years,
two years Jujitsu's mainstream.
There's like some reality show about
Jujitsu and it gets so big and people love
it. But we, we,
we have to figure out the right format
first to to make sure that there's a lot
of excitement because right now, you
know, you got to Jujitsu tournaments,
there's nobody there.
The only people in the stands or the
actual competitors and their girlfriends
and maybe their moms. It, we've been
having these world championships forever.
Nobody's going to see it cause the
point system is developed to, uh,
satisfy the competitor. Well,
it's a little bit of that,
but it's also the, just,
it hasn't been introduced, right? Yeah. It
hasn't been introduced at all. You know,
now that a spike is starting to put
glory on the highest level kickboxing,
they're putting that on TV.
I think one of these days someone's going
to realize that he watched like that
Kron Gracie, Gary Cohn and fight that
kind of a match. It's very exciting.
Let's say that, okay. Realistically, 50
years or whatever, Jujitsu is mainstream.
You could
do a show where there's a
16 man tournament submission
only and the winner one
winner only.
It's just like a any kind of reality show.
One winner gets $100,000 cash or whatever.
That's Matt.
That unrealistic. Can you imagine
the excitement of those matches?
You have a good match
maker you put together,
you know you don't just throw
people together but the x,
the amount of urgency that there
is going to be for the submission,
the training would be totally different.
People would be specifically training
their setups to the submissions.
It would be all about the submission.
Right now these guys getting the w and
winning by points is all that's necessary.
So guys are specifically training
for to for the point system.
And I'm guilty of it too. I mean, I
mean if that's, if that's the format.
This is how I understand cause I
do the same thing with Amir alum.
He wrestled his whole life.
He's one of my brown belts,
but he's a wrestler through and through.
So we were going to go in and
just say you're a wrestler.
He worked on his wrestling.
Let's beat these guys by the point system.
Let's get that w I was doing
that. I'm not like this. You know,
you're forced to think like that based
on the system because you want the w so
bad. So I'm guilty of it too. We were,
we were, we wanted to wrestle Jared. Dot.
So, you know, you, uh, you
make it a 16 man tournament,
eight man terminate.
You make it a reality show submission.
Only one guy gets $100,000. I'm going
to do, did it. But I do, you know,
if he did a million that would even
be crazier. The matches would be nuts.
All you'd have to do is just
have guys who are really good,
who are going for submissions and
going after it. And you would,
it'd be a really exciting sport.
A lot more excited than
a lot of shit that is on,
on TV and just people just don't know
about, they're just not used to it. Yeah.
It can be done. Someone just like
someone like to shake, you know,
figuring out how to do it. Yeah.
You know, it's, it's uh, you know,
and there's a lot of people that get,
they look into Jujitsu and then they
watch a match and go, fuck this,
this is boring. They're just the way
the gay sport is turning into now.
It's like I'm a black belt in the
g and I look at the new stuff.
I don't even know who's on top.
I have no idea who's winning that plan.
Tug of war with the pants
and they're in this mangled,
tangled position that I wouldn't
even know who has the advantage.
Someone got an advantage very near sweep.
I who did,
I'm considered one of the things
I wanted to ask you about cron.
He doesn't do any new shit.
Like everything he does is old school,
Jujitsu, old school, Hixon
Gracie style, the, the,
you know that,
that real basic set of techniques and
just it just get some laser sharp.
That's all he does.
He has a incredible rear naked choke
and even more insane guillotine in the
final,
he went against Oto Tavio Sousa.
He's one of the top Gracie Baha
guy at that weight at one 70.
And Oh, getting to this match. Right.
So it's the finals Hixon Gracie sitting
there or on an o Tavio they're going at
it. Oh. Tibio decides to
get inside crimes head.
And the way he's going to do that is
keep staying away from them, not engage,
slap him on the neck,
push him away. Frustrate.
Because all cron wants a submission.
Right? He's like Marcella Garcia,
he just goes forward. The submission
is on Crohn's. Mine, right. You know,
for damn sure. That's what he wants.
And uh, he kept going forward. Oh,
Teva keeps pushing away him. He's
a bad motherfucker. He got pushed.
He beat Leo Vr. I mean he's, he's
legit. One of the best. And he actually,
they weren't against each other and
metamorris and Chron beat him in the Geeky
armbar them.
It was a,
it was an epic match and the match
before that at the world. Octavio one.
So metamorris was a rematch.
He got revenge. Now the
rubber match in Abu Dhabi,
in the vinyl, he smacking his head
and conflict and over at the ref gone.
You know, what does he
doing? Just smacking my neck.
And he keeps walking backwards.
I understood what I'll Tavia was doing.
He was trying to frustrate them,
get inside of Santa. It was working.
He was getting pissed off.
But you know what it was also working
on Hixon to soon said, hey, uh,
and this is according,
I didn't hear it personally,
but this is according to what I
heard, the reports, the reporters,
it's all over the Internet.
So I may be wrong,
but it appears to be correct based on
the reports I read that Hickson was,
at first he was like telling the ref.
He keeps, he keeps going backwards.
He's not engaged and it
keeps going backwards. He's,
he doesn't even want to fight. And then
he said, he's chicken, he's chicken.
And then he starts making chicken noises.
He said, but God, bring up, bring up.
You'll imagine doing that. Isn't that
crazy? You know what that tells you, man?
You know, there's some people out
there that don't understand that.
But as a father, I, I understand it.
If I do, it's like
you're, that's your son.
You're going to make sure I
got my son murdered somebody.
I'm going to shelter him, I'm going
to hide him. You know what I'm saying?
I shouldn't talk about it.
Know what I'm saying is know what I'm
saying is you'll do anything for your kids
and what you're seeing even doing,
making chicken noises that they could
easily make you seem like you're childish.
Easy, but he don't care. All
they care is about macho.
He was willing to do anything it took
to make Octavio engage and it worked.
He engaged,
took a shot,
chron guillotine them the fastest
guillotine ever soon as he took him down,
cross sat down. Boom. It was over.
Man. I don't know if it's online,
but it was over like in three seconds
or less. Less than three seconds. Boom.
He won the world championship.
Submitted everybody.
That's amazing.
It's just amazing when you hear about a
guy who is the son of the great master,
like the greatest master ever.
It's almost like a movie, you know?
And when he was young,
you know,
like I remember hanging out with him
over at Hickson's house. You know,
she's just like a young kid.
He was talking about rap music and shit.
And of course he trained Jujitsu.
He loved Jiu Jitsu.
He loved the fact that his dad was this,
you know,
I mean imagine if that's your dad.
He's just the greatest
Jujitsu guy of all time.
He's got to be the coolest shit ever.
And he's right.
He's currently the baddest
guy in Abu Dhabi for, it's
amazing. And he's young too.
And you know what, no homo or anything.
But that guy's a, he's a beautiful man.
Was Wife was beautiful. He
in his wife, she's beautiful
Hicks. It's beautiful. Yeah.
Hixon married some supermodel back in
the day and they had a bunch of kids and
all their kids,
even hawkson and their daughters,
they all have perfect little
model faces and their Tam, he,
he could easily be a movie star there.
Their models is kids like
amber Abercrombie and Fitch
model so well when he was
in that, that documentary
choke, if that documentary,
it's really unfortunate that that didn't
become a huge documentary cause even
people who don't appreciate martial arts,
you just want to watch
something interesting.
Like people keep telling me
about the Sushi documentary,
Gen zero genes of Sushi or
whatever the fuck it's called.
It's supposed to be amazing about a
guy who was like really into Sushi.
But I'm not in the Sushi. I'm not an
about giant to be a Sushi chef. I hate it.
But if you, even if you have no
aspirations towards martial arts,
choke is an amazing documentary
because it follows this guy who's just,
he's just the, he's legit. He's legit,
masterful in everything he
does. I mean, they do it as a,
he's meditating in the fucking
freezing icy rivers of Japan.
He gets under water up to his
neck and he's, you know, he's,
he's doing his meditation,
practicing and doing yoga,
where does this weird shit
with his stomach. And yeah,
it's cool when a guy like that exists,
when there really is a bad motherfucker,
like a real,
like mystical sort of a showman Brazilian
jujitsu master who's better than
everybody else.
And that reminds me of the most surreal
moment of my Jujitsu career.
Man Was Abu Dhabi at the first way
and hits and comes up to me and says,
Hey Heddy, how are you doing? I shook
my hand, my head almost exploded.
I couldn't believe him saying
Eddie. Yeah, very strange.
It was that he knew who
you were because you know,
Cron Cron and John John are real tight.
John Joc is now a coral
belt under Hixon Gracie.
So Hixon Gracie is John jocks master now.
And uh,
he used to be Gracie Baha and under
Carlinos and on him, but now he's,
he's under Hickson and John [inaudible]
always been tight with crowd.
That's how he had that insight. That's
how he knew he was going to be a champion,
the champion that he is.
So John,
Jack Brock Cron over to my
gym maybe two weeks ago.
And that was the first time ever got to
hang out with chron and train with them.
And it was, it was pretty
amazing to have Hixon son that.
And anytime I have a Gracie there
with me that I could talk to,
my always,
I always want to remind them that there's
a big misconception about what 10 plan
of Jujitsu is all about.
And to someone who really doesn't
know and hasn't done the research,
it's easy to, it's easy to
kind of see that, oh, uh,
or easy to believe that I say turned
my back on Jujitsu. Once I got
my black belt, I threw the Goa,
I'm disrespectful to them,
understands this if they
don't follow Jiu Jitsu,
but there's two camps of Jujitsu. There's
people who train with a Geek, you know,
big bulky Kimono thing and there's no g,
which is mostly guys where rash guards
or shorts and their training basically
techniques that would work in mixed
martial arts because of the fact that the
gooey is this big piece of cloth.
People grab it and hold onto it and it,
it really changes the entire nature of,
of grappling changes everything.
Because if all you have all these
handles that you can hold onto,
it becomes really annoying.
Yeah. And a majority of the
Brazilian Jujitsu a community,
they really liked the ghee.
And I understand that it's like liking
long in your surfer and some people like
short boards.
No Nogi would be like the short board
and Longboard we'd like the key.
It's really traditional.
It looks cool.
You grow up and you see these karate
movies and you want to wear that gain.
You strap that black belt
on and you've got to key,
you feel like a superhero
because that black belt is
real. I get it. I understand.
But um,
I got into Jujitsu because of the UFC.
I became a fanatic of the UFC and Jujitsu
is the closest thing I could do to be
kind of close to the sport and understand
the sport without getting hit in the
face. I don't like boxing. I don't like
kickbox and I don't want to get hit.
But Jujitsu is awesome.
It's safe, you know,
all you're doing is practicing strangling
each other and getting really good at
that and practicing breaking limbs.
Like who doesn't want to learn that?
Anybody can learn that and you and you
don't get hurt. No one's punching you.
I was sold right when I saw the UFC.
It was oh a way for me to
be the be close to the UFC,
the sport that I worship now.
Um,
so when I see a Jujitsu
black belts in the UFC,
great with the g, but all of a sudden
they're fighting in the UFC without a,
and now they don't have
their handles and do,
they're trying to punch them and their
elbows and all that stuff. To me,
I thought the [inaudible] was the prompt.
Jujitsu wasn't looking that good.
And the UFC man and those dark
ages like UFC 17 to ou like that.
Even today, overall, the Jujitsu I
think could be a lot better if they,
if everyone's focused on
Jujitsu techniques that
worked when specifically when
dudes to trying to punch you or elbow
EU and you know, and there's no handles,
it's different. So anyways, so I was,
I loved Jujitsu so much that I was
tired of being let down by never seen.
You rarely see sweeps in the UFC.
You go to a Jujitsu class or Jujitsu
tournament where they're wearing a g,
you see sweeps and submissions for off
your back from the guard when you're on
your back all the time. But why
weren't you seeing it in the UFC? I go,
you rarely see sweeps. And even today when
you see a good quality sweep, it's woo.
It's a highlight reel.
That was an amazing sweet.
But in the ghee that happened all the
time and submissions off the back happen
all the time. So the differences,
it's just common sense in the gay,
you don't have to worry about dude's
elbowing you and you've got all these
handles and you
develop all these techniques based on
pulling the collar and holding on the
sleeve. And that becomes your
fighting stance. And when,
if that's your fighting stance and all of
a sudden you do MMA and there's no fat,
the fat fighting style
is totally different.
You're clenching now cause you
don't want to get knocked out.
You got to focus on that. So
for me, I thought, man, if
I ever opened up a school,
I'm when I'm, I never liked the gate
to begin with. Personal personally,
I'd rather train Gnocchi.
It's faster. I like it faster.
I have no problems with the gay.
A lot of my students,
they'll try in the geek personally,
it's just too slow for me.
I needed to be faster.
So when I have, uh, um,
so a lot of people in the Jiu Jitsu
community think that I turned my back on
Jujitsu. Man, nothing could be further
from the truth, I don't think any, no, no.
It was just a bunch of haters out there
and there's people that hate no matter
what, but there's no one to
focus on them. No, I just,
I just wanted to make it clear. And when
Chron came to my school two weeks ago,
I made it clear to him like,
I just want to let you know that I have
all the respect in the world for the
Gracies. Anybody that thinks
I don't is ridiculous. I mean,
in my first book that came out in 2005,
it opens up with a paragraph or two
on each Gracie and thanking them for,
for creating me and creating the sport
and the UFC. So it, and that's over,
that's like 10 years ago.
It's not anything that I'm trying to,
I'm trying to do damage
control now or anything,
so I just wanted to put that
out there that, that uh, um,
you don't have to put that up there
and nobody believes that. Hey. Um,
would you think about the
UFC this weekend? Incredible.
Those are the craziest UFC ever. Yeah,
it was going on right when I would have,
it was going on.
It was going on at a
Saturday or Sunday morning.
Was it Sunday morning and it was Saturday
morning here or something like that.
It was like,
it was weird.
So I didn't get to see it live and I don't
think it was possible to see it live.
We ended up seeing it the next
day. Uh, Amir and Scott Palmer,
another one of my students who went,
they figured out how to
find it somewhere online.
Online. Yeah. Yeah. The Diego Sanchez,
Gilbert Melendez fire was the craziest
fucking thing I've ever seen in my life.
Yeah, it was madness.
Especially that third round.
God Damn, that was incredible.
They just went off.
They just went after it in a way like
you very rarely see and for Diego to drop
Gilbert Melendez without uppercut after
all that damage he was taken. Yeah,
man. There we saw some
serious heart that night.
I mean junior dos Santos that talk
about heart. Jesus Christ. Yeah.
Dee Diego Sanchez is a special dude.
He's his belief in himself and his,
his ability to absorb punishment.
It's crazy battles.
He's bites down his mouthpiece and he
doesn't do a lot of slipping and moving,
you know? He's taken a lot of them and
just charge and forward. He loves it.
He's so crazy.
He had a giant cut over his iron man.
It was bigger than his eyebrow. It was
like the size of his eyebrow was enormous.
Yeah. There was a, there was
a whole wild fucking event.
Did you see Hector Lombard and
Nate Marquardt? Yes. Holy Shit.
I won 70 hectare. Lumbar going
to give, he'll give anybody fits.
I could see him. He can be the champ.
Yeah, easily. Easily. Yeah. Yeah.
He's terrifying at one 70
he's a freak athlete, man.
Would GSP be able to take him down?
I don't know man. I don't know.
He's a freak athlete. Well now I
use that term a lot freak athlete.
But Hector Lombard really is a freak and
at one 70 that might be the strongest
one 70 that's ever existed ever.
He hits so fucking hard dude.
He chased down Nate Marquardt who was
a strike force former champion. Okay.
Nate mark,
what was the Strikeforce welterweight
champion and Hector lumbar chased him
around like he was some kid that he
was going to assault. I mean it was,
it was amazing.
I mean he like almost like he had no
worry whatsoever about Nate Marquardt
techniques. Just ran after him, ran
after him, kept throwing bombs at them.
And then the last shocks amount last shot.
Did you see what it did to Nate's body?
Yeah.
It made him kind of like
hop and land on his,
but I can see his leg slipped
out from under him when he,
cause he was like kind of running away
and he got one of those uppercuts from
behind and then boom,
it lifted him up and he landed
right on his bud was pretty crazy.
It was horrific. Yeah. He fucked
him up, man. It was, it was spooky.
I didn't know that he was going to be
able to do that. I mean, I knew that he,
Jake, Jake Ellenberger and
Nate Marquardt had a, uh,
a real tough fight and
Nate got knocked out,
but they were going after
each other, you know? I mean,
Nate was going after him
too. It was a real, it was,
he got caught with a big
shot by Ellenberger and
Ellenberger can take anybody
out. But it was competitive up until
that, this was not competitive.
This was a mugging. I mean, he
just came after Nate Marquardt,
Nate Marquardt try to counter him
a couple of times at right hands.
But mostly it was just trying
to get the fuck out of the way.
And that dude just came at him like, oh,
like a monster. It was weird. It was.
He's ridiculously strong.
Yeah. Is it's scary dude.
At 170 pounds.
I want immediately to see matches
with him against like Carlos condit
immediately to see him.
He him against guys like Johnny Hendricks
or George see AP or whoever wins the
title. According to Eric
Paulson, I had him on my podcast.
He's telling me some Hector
Lombard stories. Man,
the guy is intense,
24 seven in the gym,
wants to throw down him and Josh Barnett.
Throat threw down at least once.
Yeah. Josh told me about Josh. Josh
mounted him and would never let them up.
We just beating on him.
He wouldn't let him up as apparently
he had an issue with something lumbar.
Did someone else in the gym,
so Josh and him just went after it.
Josh said the guy's a freak athlete.
He said he does those muscle ups,
you know those things where you do a chin
up and then you push up from the top.
They're really hard to do.
This is a motherfucker just,
he'd never done it before.
I banged out like 10 in a row. Boom, boom.
I don't think I'll ever be able to do one.
He's a freak athlete.
Like when you look at his body, he's
five foot seven and five foot seven wide.
You know,
he's so big.
Mimi's probably probably about five nine
they probably a little taller than me
think.
I Dunno my hydro five maybe my either
my height or maybe slightly taller.
I'm five eight but he's twice
as wide as man. I mean he might,
he might and I'm pretty wide. You might
be like literally a foot wider than me.
Yeah, he, I think it's an
illusion. He's actually,
he might be five 10 but he says last
are so wide and the shoulders that it
appears that he's five fours,
he's so wide.
I've never seen a dude his height
that wide before and the power that
motherfucker has, God damn, it's scary.
Scary and just ultimate confidence
in his ability to knock guys out.
Ultimate confidence. Like as he
charged in on Nate, it was just,
he knew it was a matter of time. It
was weird. It was weird to watch.
I never thought I'd watched Nate get
steam steamrolled like that. You know,
you think about Nate.
Nate fought Anderson Silva.
It was a decent fight until Anderson a
reversed him on the ground and beat him
up and stopped him.
But it was a decent fight before that.
Nate fought Tyron Woodley and knocked him
out. I mean, Nate is a bad motherfucker.
He's a really good fighter. You don't
think of all the guys he's knocked out.
He knocked out Martin and Martin Kampmann,
you know named mark. No fucking joke.
He's been around a long ass time too.
He's really fucking gold bar.
It's got that Hendricks power. Just
boom. But he's got in both hands. Yeah.
He's this terrifying, terrifying
Lombard's. Terrifying.
He might be the motherfucker at one 70
men. It really might be. Yes, it might be.
So these guys, man, sometimes it's
just a matter of making that weight.
Getting minding the weight class. Yeah.
Look at Damien Maia at one seven eight.
Yeah, no, but then Jake shields
beat him, which is crazy.
I could have went either way.
Yeah, it was a, it was a,
I think one of those fights that easily
could be a draw. You can decide who wins,
but my, it didn't happen. You know, that
a lot of people were saying to mio is,
was going to dominate him the way he
dominated Rick story. Yeah, yeah. No.
If people forget how good
a Rambo Jake shields. Yeah,
yeah. He never really got close
to any submissions. And the, the,
and Jake,
he's probably top three if
not the best passer in MMA.
His passing,
his incredible,
him and Sean sherk incredible passing
and Jake almost passed so many times,
God. And to have that kind of confidence
that tried to pass Maya's guard,
most receptors we'll just say, okay,
in this fight or you get on top,
don't even try to pass.
But Jake kept trying to pass
and even though even though he,
he didn't quite make it,
it was very impressive that he had the
confidence to keep pushing and keep
trying to pass. And Damen Meier really
can do anything off his back against Jake.
Jake's Easter, having guys attack them,
you know, serious guys off their back.
So man, that was a very, very close fight.
I thought they would give it to
Maya base because it was in Brazil.
I thought Jake's really
gonna have to beat him.
He's decisively to get it in Brazil.
But, uh, that wasn't the case after all.
So congratulations to Jake.
Yeah,
that was a big win for him.
Cause Maya was on the verge of a
title shot after the Rick Story fight.
If they're beaten, John Fitch, he,
John Fitch, John Fitch, and then, uh,
beat Rick story like that.
A lot of people like Jesus Christ.
This guy might be the best grappler
in the division. No one can stop him.
So Jake wins that fight,
derails his title,
hopes that this is just so many
good fighters now, man, it's crazy.
Robbie Lawler is about the fight.
Rory Macdonald.
How fucking crazy is that fight?
Can at the Wahhabi, Laura at one 70.
And this is another one at once 70.
It's fucking terrifying.
He's absolutely terrified.
What 70 did you see? Um,
uh, Ama golf and, uh, Tj walberger.
Robbie Lawler knocked out.
I'm a God with a flying knee.
That's how scary Robbie Lawler,
I'll never forget Dana white
at the comedy store years ago,
telling you about Robbie Lawler for
the first time it was, I got this kid,
Robbie Lawler bad knock
you out with both hands.
I remember hearing that
and then he brought him up.
He did well in the beginning and then
he started fighting for Strikeforce.
He was fighting an 85 you shouldn't have
been fighting in 85 we should have been
funny at one 70 and the whole time.
But he also needed to mature,
come into his own,
you know,
he's like 30 now and now he's like a
real legit professional, you know, he,
he, he fights smart. He doesn't
just wing punches a guys,
but it does still wing punches that guys,
he's got a serious fucking Chin and
he goes after guys. Does that fight?
That's November.
That's the George Saint Pierre undercard.
Good googly Mowgli, dude.
Roy MacDonald and, and and
I mean, think about that camp that
Tristar camp, Brian McDonald GSP.
He got so many good guys out of that.
Can't that Francis car, Hmong guy.
But Robbie Lawler is a mother fucker.
I don't know who's gonna win that fight.
He's like, super technical. Doesn't take
too many chances. Works on that Long Jab,
you know? But Robbie Lawler, we'll go
after a motherfucker. Yeah, he spooky.
What'd you think of Roy Nelson core? Me
a Carmine's a fucking sick athlete, man.
He's a sick, you're going to two oh
five yeah, he's going, he went to fight.
Jon Jones was saying it. He was
saying, I'm going into a five. Yeah,
he'll be at two oh five he was two
24 for this fight. You know, he'll,
he'll go down to a five and he's
going to be a handful for everybody.
He's that elite Olympic gold medalist,
caliber athlete.
Those motherfuckers are rare dudes.
You know those dudes,
they break their hand and keep punching
you with it until it falls apart.
He was thrilled. His throwing punches
at Josh Barnett with a broken hand.
You know,
he's taking Josh Barnett up in the air
with a broken hand slamming on the ground
with,
you know,
he's fucking bones are rattling against
themselves inside of his hand to do that.
To Josh Barnett, man. Exactly.
That's what I just had to be out of
this world and he's not even a legit
heavyweight.
He wrestled at two oh six I think he
wrestled it to a six it was definitely
light because he had a cut weight to do
it and that's why he lost his bid at the
Olympics because he had kidney failure
because he tried to make the weight.
We try to cut the way, like cut a lot
of weight and he fucked himself up.
A lot of guys have that man, you know, I'm
Josie Aldo has kidney stones now.
Had a kidney stone removed after
his fight with the Korean Zombie.
That's from cutting weight.
Yeah.
One of my students had
kidney stones and and since,
since he went to the hospital,
went through all the excruciating pain
and me hearing the stories, he said, bro,
drink cranberry juice. Pure
cranberry juice. Don't drink
that cocktail every day.
You do not want to go through what
I went through. I swear to God,
I have pure cranberry
juice in my refrigerator.
I make sure my wife keeps it
stocked and I drink it every day.
Just hearing his story of excruciating
pain and the hospital does this guy.
Who Was it? Which guy? Um, I don't know.
I don't want to say is does
he cut weight? He, yes.
He cuts massive white. Shut it down. Yeah,
he sure is. He's, is it cut weight to,
to do matches? Yeah. Fuck
man, that Shit's bad for you.
Cutting weight is not good,
but if you want to be a great fighter
and just drink pure Granbury cranberry
juice, not the cocktail. And you should
be fine every day. It tastes like shit.
Tastes sour, but it's like a
shot at drink it every day.
Get it to make it whole foods.
You can get it at a, anyway,
any supermarket and it's a cranberry
pills. That's a, does the same thing.
Does it do this? Just take
a shot. A shot of cramp.
How could it do the same thing
though? It never does. You know,
like you take those like, um, pills, green
pills, they're never as good as it was.
Like real we to choose. It's kind
of sour, but you get used to it.
It's actually not bad and you can't
drink that much of it. So it's perfect.
It's like a way to quench your thirst and
you're not going to down like half the
bottle. If it was grape drink or
something, shit, you kill half the bottle.
But since it's so tart, you're forced
to only take a sip. And so that,
what does that do? What? What's
in it that protects your deck?
It's gotta be the acid in
it cause it's kind of sour.
It's gotta be has something to do with
that and making sure that those stones
are always broken down. It's probably
just melt some or something. I don't know.
I stayed this girl who used to
get 'em urinary tract infections.
She seems to have to drink cranberry
juice to get rid of it. How weird is that?
Cranberry juice is legit. It's weird that
there's foods though that cure things,
you know, like do you have any stomach
ailments and think bothering your stomach?
Take garlic. It's
incredible. Like, if you,
if you eat some bad food and get some
sort of stomach like food poising shit
like that,
eat some cloves of garlic.
It's like sending in rabid Italian troops
to go down in there and just fuck off
all the bacteria. It's incredible.
And people who don't like raw garlic,
you don't know what you're missing.
Just eat cloves of that shit.
That's fantastic for you.
It's like an assault on all the
shitty things inside your body.
How about that Tony Ferguson? Marce Damn.
Why is it called a Mars? Well, you know,
cause you,
you,
you got a name every move
and every position and every
transition in my opinion
to in order to teach at the highest level.
So there's a difference between getting
a dark when you're on top and you're
using your weight. He wasn't on top.
He cinched it in and went
to his back and mark laymen,
he's a very well known MMA jujitsu
coach. Uh, he used to do that.
He's the one who actually called it the
doors when it was named after the first
guy he saw use it. Joe, Doris, and
I think his name is DRC. That's,
that's who mark layman is very similar
to me as we'd like to name everything
that doesn't have names and lots of
Jujitsu moves didn't, so you got a name,
there's a difference between the
marks cause the Marsis on your back.
And that's how he used to do it. He,
he said that was his thing that he did.
His squeeze was so tight that he didn't
need to be on top and he'd like rolling
guys and they didn't expect it.
And so he called it the marsh.
There's also off a force,
which I don't know if a guy
named Freddy made it up.
I don't know the story behind farce,
but that's when you're kind of
mounting the guy and you have,
you are mounting the guy in
the habit doors. So there's,
there's a different variations of it and
the one that Tony Transit, 10th planet,
Costa Mesa all week and every Thursday
he comes up and trains with me.
And that's the move you got to
watch when you're on with Tony.
He does flying darcis man,
he's, he's, I mean his,
his Jujitsu is very underrated man. He's
going to shock a lot of people over the,
over the his career.
Well that Darcy did,
he hit that dude with,
he immediately scooted under him and
then almost like an inverted crucifix and
ties his arm up with
his legs from the bottom
as that confidence in your
squeeze to do that. Yeah.
So that tells you a lot. Yeah. Wow.
You don't ever see
anybody going to the Mars.
You see people going to the Darce and if
the guy on the bottom roles you should
be able to roll with them even if it
turns into a Mars still finish it.
But you don't go there voluntarily
unless you have your super confident with
them.
Having those long arms is such a
massive advantage. It really is. Yeah.
As far as like that leverage
that you can get with long limbs,
it's really incredible. Guys who have
like wicked Darcy's and have long arms,
they can just like shove them
under platelet Kendall Grove.
Kendall Grove used to catch them and
all sorts of weird spots cause he could
just, he had like an extra foot
on his arms. Yup. Jeff Glover is,
well he's one of the best at Darcy's.
Jeff Glover lets you pass him.
I love that move where he lets you get
into side control and you think you're
going to assign control but
really just go into Darcel land.
It just catches it in. The transition
is Jujitsu for people don't know.
It's so fucking technical. There's
so many techniques. I mean it's,
it's truly amazing when you
stop and consider the positions,
the amount of different possibilities
each position holds and then different
ways to submit people and
are they all flow together?
If you've never done it before,
it's hard to kind of understand it.
And I know that's one
of the things that I,
I take a lot of time on when it comes
to uh, uh, ground battle in the UFC.
I always make sure I try to
explain what a guy is trying to do,
where it becomes a, where he's, you know,
where he's going to and people get
a chance to see it more that way.
But unless you train yourself,
you'll never really truly understand
the beauty of it. If you train yourself,
you'll get a sense of what it's like to
struggle to actually catch a guy in a
position. Then you'll understand how
amazing it is when you see like really,
really high level stuff. When you see
a mad scramble at Kron Gracie and uh,
Gary Tona and Gary taken Crohn's back and
that wild scramble, they kept rolling,
Kep Rolling, kept rolling that Pam
locks up the body triangle like, fuck.
Yeah, yeah, it's, it's uh,
it's an art that anybody can do. Children,
old ladies, they all do it. It's really,
really easy. It's, I'm
not trying to sell it to,
obviously I want to make money,
but it's the truth.
The truth is anybody can learn it.
All you have to do to show up to your
local Jujitsu school and just watch,
just go and just watch a couple times.
It's free. You don't have to commit to it.
Just tell the guy you want to watch and
you watch and you realize all my God,
I had it all wrong.
You know,
yet you expect that you're gonna show
up and there's going to be all these
fucking douchebags killing each
other and bleeding on each other.
And you realize it's a bunch of nerds.
It's a bunch of computer nerds. And,
and after you,
after you watched one class,
you should be sold on it and you
don't have to roll. And Do, you know,
people are scared of rolling and oh,
would it be taps and hurts me.
It's so rare that anybody
gets hurt. Really. It so rare
usually get hurt more from positions
than you do from submissions.
You get hurt more when you leg gets
tripped on to you, but you know,
as you get better at it, that becomes
less than the last. And as you,
if you're in a good school,
like 10th planet or like there's so many
good schools in La and we get spoiled,
but most places have to be good in
order to stay open in this day and age
because there's so much competition.
Does amazing amounts of competition.
Yeah.
From Jujitsu are beginning classes are,
we kind of changed up a
little over the years.
I realized that most people are a lot
more scared of going to a Jujitsu class
and checking it out and taking
one class than I thought.
They're way more scared than I thought.
So I understand that. I used to,
I used to think that,
you know,
if you should know that it's a safe sport
and you should know if you want to do
it or not. And if you're not totally into
it, I don't want to talk you into it.
You should just know.
And then that leaves me with a
small percentage of the population,
which I consider you're my family.
But in reality,
if uh, I changed my beginner
classes and make them more,
cater more to the guys that want to do it.
But they're just scared of debt.
They're scared of death
of signing a contract.
They're scared to death of getting hurt.
They're coming into Jujitsu is scared.
So you got to really think about,
uh,
just walking them through it nice and
slowly showing them that there's nothing
to be scared of. This is a beautiful
thing that everyone can learn.
You can learn to get really good at
putting people to sleep in six months.
You know, another thing is,
um, don't be afraid to tap.
That's another thing that I,
I make sure I really tell people,
it's nothing wrong with tapping.
It's not that bad. Just go
in there and tap. It's, it's,
you've got to think about it.
Like someone's scoring a point on you
in basketball, it's going to happen.
It's totally normal. Yeah.
And once you get past that,
and especially if you're training with
good people, you tap them, they tap you.
Doesn't matter.
It's good for you.
And if you can't have a guy but
he can cat tap you, guess what?
That's good for you too. It's good for
you to know that someone can tap you.
You need to up your game and up your
skill level to get to the point where he's
at, but just because he taps it
was no big deal. It doesn't matter.
People tapped people all the time.
That's one of the biggest reasons
people are afraid to come in and they're
afraid to lose this game of death
cause really that's why Jujitsu is so
fascinating and such a beautiful thing
because really it applies to life in on
the streets, saving your family,
protecting your, your children,
protecting your wife,
your wife, protecting your
children and back and forth,
your children knowing Jujitsu and
protecting their father and son, you know,
whole family where everyone does Jujitsu.
That's increases your chances,
chances of survival and like some
apocalyptic era. Well either way,
it's a great way to exercise.
It's a great discipline. It's,
it's great for your body.
It's great for your mind.
Like after we leave Jujitsu class,
tell me when we more like loose,
relax and silly.
Then after Jujitsu meals like to
leave the parking lot after Jujitsu
conversations where everybody's exhausted.
You've been fighting for your life for
the past hour and a half and we're all
just hanging out,
chilling,
and tried to kill each other just an
hour before virtual reality. Exactly,
and you get used to that.
It becomes a normal thing for folks
where it's not a normal thing.
It seems daunting. It seems terrifying.
It seems uninviting, but believe me,
I know a lot of, like you
said, nerds and it's a lot,
a lot of Nice people in Jujitsu to people
who have a good control of their ego.
We've, we've talked about that
on this podcast many times,
but I think it needs
repeating and it's absolutely,
I can't tell you how many
tweets, emails, messages,
how many,
I guess I listened to you guys talk about
Jujitsu on the podcast over and over,
and then I finally went to a school and
I tried it and guess what? You are right.
This is amazing. This is changing
my life. My son's doing it now too.
It's toe and that is
the most likely outcome.
If you give it a shot and you have an
open mind and leave your ego at the door
is it's gonna Change your life for
the going to give you without a doubt,
it's going to be one of the best vehicles
for developing your confidence that
you can ever find. It will change
your confidence. And that's women,
including women.
You know,
like think about a women that
you know that have gone to,
your school's gone to different Jujitsu
classes and gotten better at it and then
they become like more relaxed person.
They become a different person.
They're not worried about their
self defense around men anymore.
They know that the reality is a
girl is a brown belt in Jujitsu.
Like remember when we had Felicia do
that thing with Seymour Butts? Yes.
Explain any more bucks is a nice guy.
He's a porn star and a porn
producer and he had a show
on showtime on showtime.
I don't remember what the name of it was.
Do you remember the show?
Maybe we'll just see more butts. I
don't remember what it was. But anyway,
real nice guy. And one of the episodes,
he wanted to come down and do Jujitsu. Uh,
with a woman? No, no, no. He just wanted
to come down and do Jujitsu. Oh really?
It was not with a woman.
He didn't want to do it with Felicia.
Did you set that up by
Harvard? Felicia. Oh,
who's a friend of ours.
She's a black belt under John Jacques
Machado and a legit bonafide bad ass.
She's like 135 pounds. She's not a
big woman, but she is strong as fuck.
And her Jujitsu is top notch and she's
really smart. She's super, super,
super smart.
So she just gets good at anything.
She just knows how to get good at shit
and her and see more butts rolled.
It was like his first day and
she man handled this poor lad.
He didn't get hurt. He just
lost the game. She was so nice.
Never feels amazing when you tap
out, it doesn't feel refreshing. No,
and that's why it's so beautiful
because it didn't feel good.
You just lost a game of death.
No one got hurt.
But that tap represented the fact
that he had your life in his hands.
And the only reason he let go his cause
he's a cool guy and everyone's cool in
class. But in reality of if he, if he was
a Douche bag and he wanted to kill you,
he could have, yeah, they take your life.
If someone wanted to choke you out and
then stomp your head out while your
unconscious, that's what happens. But the
point is, Felicia, being a small woman,
uh, just, just using her technique, just
tapped him over and over and over again,
got an a triangle, got his
back, got him in an arm bar.
And the way she did it was so fluid and
beautiful and you watch the episode, it,
it doesn't,
I don't think it goes down like that.
They edit it to make him look good because
we shot a segment where I'm teaching
and I'm teaching him and we're doing the
teaching segment. And then I asked them,
do you want to roll to, cause he
didn't even know where like rolling,
we kind of spar and he said, yeah, yeah,
we'll shoot that and we'll do that.
And I go, well we'll spar with the woman
you know and make it. And it was like, ah,
okay. Whatever. That was
your idea. That is so funny.
It was so long ago I forgot.
Yeah.
Generally if you're a girl out there and
you do Jujitsu for solid for one year
solid you,
the chances of you getting
raped go down significantly.
It's very hard to rape a Jujitsu girl
and it doesn't take that long to get good
at what it said within two years.
Time flies you,
they'll be doing it three years just
like that. And you're a bad ass.
The last time I rolled with Felicia,
I think I was a purple belt.
I might've been a brown belt,
was either purple or brown belt and it's
not like I was like trying to kill her,
but I didn't tag her but didn't dabber.
So he's 135 pounds and she just fucking
good man. Really? She's fucking,
she's really strong and she's fucking
good. And when someone's really good,
they know how to put themselves in the
perfect position and they know how to
keep,
they know how to keep getting away from
anything that you're trying to do to
them and putting themselves in a better
position to defend a better position to
attack that being many steps ahead of
the person you're doing it with because
they don't know what you're doing. Give
someone a massive amount of confidence.
And I've seen girls go into Jujitsu class,
start getting good,
and then start tapping out guys.
And when they start tapping out
guys is a wild thing to watch.
It's a wild thing to see the guy's face.
It's a wild thing to see
a girl like cinch up.
First girl I ever saw type of dude out
was his girl junk and he used to roll
with, they were both beginners. And uh,
do you remember we got Dunkin and Ari
gave them a free year for like Christmas.
Do you remember that? Uh,
yes. Yeah, very well. Ari,
Ari stuck it out. Are he got some taps
in? Not some dudes. He kept going,
but Dunkin ran into this girl who
was very pretty and very girly,
but she tapped him with the quickness,
like how many times did she tab?
I'm just happy with like several.
It was ugly, but that was,
it was fascinating to watch.
Like this girl realizing like she could,
if she knew the techniques better,
she could get a guy.
The guy's probably stronger than her.
She can still get them that
scarred Duncan. He, no,
he didn't lie.
I think he showed up to maybe
a handful of classes at most.
He already stuck it out for awhile.
Yeah, but with Ari, he got hurt. He,
something happened to his knee, I
think. Got a staff and then he had a,
well he had an meniscus surgery
and then he got staff. Yeah,
and that was too much. You
couldn't take it. Some people.
There's a small percentage of people that
get hurt doing Jujitsu and that scares
them and they never want to
come back with generally,
most of the people who do what you did
to love it so much that the first thing
they think of when they get hurt,
they're pissed off because they're
going to be out for six weeks or they're
going to be out for three months.
They're going, that's why they're pissed.
They can't wait to get back.
And you can't wait to get
back so much that you're like,
you see a lot of times you come back too
early and you're not really healed ride
and then you reinjure yourself.
So that's generally,
if you come in with an open mind
and you leave your ego at the door,
generally you're going to fall in love
with it. It's going to change your life.
And when you get hurt,
you're more bummed about missing Jujitsu
than you are about the actual injury,
you know?
But there are some people that they might,
they get ringworm once and they're like,
fuck this.
You get what you want me to
except ring warm. You know,
it's very easy to eliminate ringworm.
You never have to deal with it.
If you can be consistent with the yogurt
and the acid office and defense soap,
get some defense.
So absolute tell everybody is the best.
And it's a great company owned
by great guy in the company.
They said they support wrestlers and
they developed soap that cleans your skin
without fucking up all the natural
bacteria. All the healthy for.
I was resistant to defense.
So for a while I never really looked
into it in the very beginning.
I thought it was so self that
had all these antibiotics,
antibiotics, and chemicals that I didn't
want to have nothing to do with it.
It just sounded like that.
But when I finally looked into it and
found out that it was just eucalyptus,
eucalyptus oil and
oil at in high amounts,
it's like wait like three times
the amount that you find it.
And I bring that everywhere
on the road with me. I don't,
I don't go to a hotel room
unless I have that sheet.
I use deep defense soap every day,
every day.
Now once I found out it was all natural
and I was sold and now that I don't need
shampoo anymore, I use it on the top
of my head too. I use it everywhere.
I use it a shampoo. Damn
you crazy. You crazy.
That keeps dandruff away cause Dandruff
is a form of fungus similar to ringworm.
Totally makes sense.
Yeah.
Well healthy skin flora is something
that people don't even think about.
But you know,
I mean that's what killed
a lot of motherfuckers back
in the day when people got
scratched and you know, they got some
sort of infection and you know, they,
they, people used to dive
infections all the time.
That's like one of the biggest death.
So it was the biggest scary things
about going into a hospital today is
infections.
You know,
and you can do a little bit to
prevent that stuff by healthy diet.
Eating a lot of probiotics.
Even if you're a Vegan,
say if you only eat vegetables,
you could still get probiotics in
the form of Sauerkraut. Sauerkraut,
like natural, raw sauerkraut.
Super good for you.
Can have acid off pills.
Well see they shouldn't even really have
Kombucha because Kombucha is a fungus
and the fungus is actually closer to a,
a person than an aunt than a plant is.
Funguses are actually closer to human
beings and plants are funguses are
actually much more like an animal
than they are like a plant.
So if you're a true Vegan
and you're eating Kombucha,
you're kind of a hypocrite.
The mushrooms, you're kind of a
hypocrite. Too Shallow. But the,
I mean that's probably,
they actually probably want you to eat
him and that's the whole idea behind
silicide. [inaudible] silicide
been wants you to eat it.
That's why it's big and
white and gigantic. It's it,
it shows up like it shows
itself very easily on a,
on like a cow patties and shit like that.
Like it's literally like
inviting you to come and eat it.
Cause that's how it communicates
with the light. Yeah. I mean come on.
How beautiful red ones,
right? Yeah. Beautiful though.
Let's say Amanita Mascara,
but silicide been the ones that grow
on cow shit. They have, you know,
the big giant ones in the Amazon.
They grow the size of dinner plates,
what's the difference?
They both get you to that other dimension.
Am Anita miscarry is a very
controversial mushroom.
And for folks who never heard of the
Amnesia miscarry and had one red one with
the white spots, it's
literally Santa Claus. Okay.
And I'll break it down real quick. For
people who have never heard this before,
go to my wife. Look, look up Joe Google.
Joe Rogan a Santa Claus was a mushroom.
I wrote a whole article about it and like
to balance the 2006 or something like
that on my website.
And what I'm about to explain,
I'm gonna have to explain to people,
okay,
the Amanita miscarry and mushroom
is native to Siberia, to Europe.
It's a different mushroom,
the mushroom,
the psilocybin mushroom that you see
in tropical climates. And you also,
we've seen a lot of places now the Pacific
northwest has a lot of, um, it's that,
that's a different experience and that's
a much more accessible experience and
it's much more reliable experience.
The AMANITA Mascara oftentimes
isn't even psychoactive.
Like they don't know what makes
it psychoactive and what doesn't.
There's all sorts of speculation that
it could be a genetically variable.
It could be seasonally
variable. It could be, you know,
the strains of it that grew in certain
areas and they were super potent,
but they don't exist anymore.
Or You have to find,
I've never had a good Amanita miscarry
trip. I only had one, um, to speak of.
That was, uh, that really blew it out.
But we took 'em we took silicide been to,
we took damn Anita for like an hour and
it wasn't doing shit. Is that us? No, no,
no. It was me and Stan. Hope me, Stan
Hope and um, Yon Urban, how many grams?
He made this weird soup. He made like a
tea with the, uh, the Amanita Mascara.
Like he knows how to do all that shit.
He's yon is pretty well versed in how to
prepare these things. There was amount,
an amount, a specific amount that tends
Mckenna and five, about five grand. Five.
Well, that's, that's,
that's silicide and this is the
[inaudible] scary like I was saying. Okay.
So we took that and then,
uh, an hour or so in,
we decided to jump it with psilocybin
and then when we jumped it with silicide
man, wow. The, the two of them together,
it was pretty fucking intense and it was
the day of the war. So it was really,
really, really weird. And we
had this motto de Cocoa Tea.
It's a,
it's cocaine tea.
It's tea that's a derived
from cocoa leaves.
Like natural coca leaves is
more shear that yon had legal,
I don't want to believe so
I would say nay. But uh,
it should be because the, the actual
leaves themselves in these indigenous
high altitude hurting populations,
they just chew them,
could shoot them all day and it's like
tobacco to them or like anything else
that people normally
have. It's like, you know,
like chewing gum or something like
that and it provides a clean stimulant.
It's when you break it down
and turn it into cocaine,
then it becomes like a real fucking pain
in the ass comes addictive and you know,
people get weirded out on it,
but they say it's actually better for
you than coffee if you just chew the
leaves. I, I just found out within the
last year I saw a documentary on where uh,
ecstasy comes from the, the, the
ingredient Mtma, right? Yeah.
It comes from these trees
in Thailand and Cambodia.
They're like chopping down all these
trees to get like the inner core of it.
And that's what makes ecstasy.
How crazy is that?
Like a pure lab created thing?
I did too.
I think there was a vice documentary
on it. Another fucking vice one.
Those vice guys are on top of everything.
Maybe that's the one I saw, probably.
Yes.
But it was fascinating.
It all comes from Cambodia and Thailand
and there's a lot of violence associated
with where these trees are now because
people are killing people to try to get
to these trees. Crazy.
Yeah. I wonder what, uh,
how that would be like taking it naturally
like right from the tree. I know,
right?
I wonder if you could,
that's the truth.
That's a movie.
A group of guys that go find
a tree that's like three hot
chicks.
All the chicks die of course within the
first 45 minutes or one survives only
one at the end.
Ecstasy is a funny one,
man. It's a really funny one. It's a
really interesting one because it's a,
it's thought of as like a
party drug and it certainly is,
but you can learn a lot on ecstasy.
Man. I've only done it once,
but I learned a lot. I had a very
beneficial trip. I paid the price with my,
my, my mental health for the last couple
of days afterwards I was wrecked. Yeah,
and my brain was not working well,
come down. It's terrible for me.
It was for some people apparently is not.
Or if you take five HTP supposedly
if you a you down five HTP, new mood.
That's why that's five HTP as well.
We moved.
It has a nail trim specifically
created for the party or well,
used to be a roll on roll on and roll off.
Do you remember?
Are you joking around really serious? You
don't remember. Don't remember. Roll on.
Aubrey created it.
The,
the original thing was RB likes to
party and he created it to two k for the
comedown off ecstasy because five HTP,
new mood became right, sort of. It became,
it was enhanced and now new mood has a
bunch of different shit in and like Elle
trip to fan which converts to five HTP.
So it has like a time release, etc. Yeah.
Well it's better in that there's more
than one mechanism for converting five HDP
to Serotonin.
The El trip to fan converts to five HTP,
which to convert to Serotonin.
It gives you the building
blocks to replenish your
serotonin surprise after you
do something like that,
but also gives you the extra
serotonin throughout your day would,
which picks your mood up so much self
man that they save for people who are
taking ssrs or antidepressants,
they tell them not to take
five HTP because Neal Brennan,
you know Neal Brennan,
the dude who I met from the show,
he uh,
was on five HTP but it was
also taken an antidepressant.
The doctor told him to lay off the five
HTP cause he would give him too much
serotonin. Huh? Yeah. That's for
real. Oh, it's definitely for real.
Have you tried any of that shit?
Well, I will say this, uh,
Depeche mode was just in town last month
and after the Depeche mode concert,
I did take some new mood.
Took about four of them.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah, I see what you're saying.
Without saying you're talking about it.
Know he should've done,
he should've taken alpha brain before
the Depeche mode concert and you wouldn't
smart enough to not go
oh,
oh no.
Oh No.
I
sold out the staples center
three nights in a row. Come on.
We haven't had a hit singles, 10 years
flight status, old friend of ours,
I think you were friends with them.
I was friends with him.
He used to work at the comedy store.
I was murdered last night.
I don't ever remember.
Katie used to work there.
I at the comedy store and he
recently moved to Las Las Vegas.
And what happened is this
gunman came into at night club,
I believe it took a comms and a
shot, two uh, two guys and then, uh,
he was just a supposedly a guy that was
at this club and he tried to tackle guy
because he's, the guy was pointing
his gun too, like innocent people.
So he was like doing a hero thing and
then he got shot. And you remember,
I don't know if you remember,
Katie is one of the nicest guy
I was dating Katie. No, no, his
name was Kay. His name's Katy. Katy.
Yeah. We talked about Katie yesterday
on the podcast. I'll hilarious. She was,
that makes a k d was
wanting to actually my,
one of my first friends in Los Angeles
when I first moved there. That's terrible.
Fuck man. There was another
school shooting the other day too.
Did you hear about that
shit? Yeah. Real quick.
Let's really get to the school shooting
back to the mushroom thing. I'm reading.
Oh yeah.
We didn't even describe the difference.
I'm reading a baby book and this is,
this is back the mushrooms and I will,
I've never read so many God damn books
in my life over the last six months.
My kid, that's his favorite shit
is to have, he goes, grabs a book.
We have 1000 bucks.
He grabs his favorite,
but when he sits on my lap and I read it,
he loves that.
He knows what the last page is. And
I'll flip it over, start it over. Sorry.
Start it over.
And there's this one book about Nicholas
the bunny and he's talking about how in
the fall I like to watch the leaves.
And then in the winter I find shelter
from the rain under a toadstool and uh,
and it's a mushroom. I never heard
mushrooms, uh, called toadstools before.
Why is it cause,
and then on the other side,
there's a mushroom with a tote actually
sitting on top of the mushroom, right?
Yeah. They'd been called
toadstools forever. But they also,
if you look up any old
school Christmas shit. Yeah.
All old school Christmas cards, anything
with elves, they all have mushrooms them.
And they have that mushroom to Amanita
miscarry mushroom. Don't, isn't there,
isn't there a myth that if you lick
a frog's ass, you get high? No,
it's not a myth at all. It's real. Some
frogs, frogs. It's different though.
What they have is five Meo DMT in them.
But what I'm saying is I
open up this baby book.
There's a little bunny Nicholas the bunny
hiding under a toadstool and then they
show a mushroom and a frog on
top of it sitting down on it.
So maybe that's why, uh,
when you lick a frog's ass,
you get high because they
actually sit on mushrooms.
Maybe they're using the mushroom
texted. We don't extract. Listen,
you don't look a frog's ass. You don't
lick a frog to get high the way there's,
this doesn't work. [inaudible]
Grecian. Yeah. This is what it is.
There's an excretion from certain types
of Frog's skin and you have to rub it on
glass. So you take this frog and you rub
them on glass and they'll excrete their
substance on the grass. Then you take that
glass, you put in the sun, it dries out.
Then you take a razor blade and you
scrape it off the glass and it's a white
powder. You smoked that white powder and
it's five methoxy dimethyltryptamine.
Now is that secretion coming from the
rectum? It's coming from their skin. Okay.
It's that whole thing of licking a
frog is just one of those urban myths.
It just, it's just weird than
an a baby book. You'll see.
You hear about the mess of licking frogs
ass and they're sitting on maybe cause
you know you, some people put ecstasy
pills in their ass for better absorption.
You heard of that Brian?
Right? So maybe the frog is
trying to get high and maybe they figured
out how to get high by sitting on a
mushroom.
It goes up their ass and they get home
and then you lick a frog's ass and you
gotta. That's all I'm saying.
This was in a baby book,
the name of the frog, it's
called the Bufo. I'll reassess
and you can't get followed by looking at,
if I remember correctly,
it's super concentrated and
super dangerous though to
do it. To get to lick it,
lick it because it's really
cool. I remember I bought
the, I bought the uh, yeah,
you got to Google shit like that. Bottom
frog to do this and I been looks called
Bufo. I'll various, yeah, cob,
it's called the Colorado river towed or
Sonoran desert toad contains five Meo
DMT and Bufo Tenon Bufo Photon,
the photon and be Ufo.
T. E. N. I. N.
There's a website that sell,
sold these frogs.
And so I bought one and I had it for
like a month that I was like, damn,
that dude, was it alive? So you never
licked it. I don't even know when ever.
I think it's a myth. If you had it, why
don't you lick it? I mean, I don't know.
I was too scared. Can you,
can you Google licking frogs?
The toads fandom has concentrated on
the surface of its skin and that's why
licking is dangerous. Smoking
is a different story, however.
Yeah.
Um,
so it's too powerful. If you look at
two powerful because it's concentrated.
Hmm. The toxic ingredient, the
toads venom is called [inaudible],
which is burned off all smoking.
That's why it's dangerous because the
two things are in it. If you burn it off,
what's left is five Meo DMT. So you don't
want to lick it because if you lick it,
it gives you [inaudible]. But photo
named gets burned off while you smoke it.
That's why it's dangerous toys.
Yeah. So I guess it really butthole.
So listen to this. This is what's
weird. It's a, this, this frog.
They're native to the Colorado
River or a southern Arizona,
California and northern New Mexico.
Even though five Ameo DMT is
classified as an unscheduled substance,
which means it's legal to possess.
But the venom also contains [inaudible],
which is scheduled.
So you all you do,
you can be in possession of an illegal
substance even though it's not a
psychedelic.
The weird thing about five Meo,
it's stronger than nn DMT and,
and DMT is the one that
gives you the crazy visuals.
But the stuff that we did the
first time, that's five me. Oh,
it's even stronger than nn and it's legal.
The one where I was screaming. Yeah,
they did. They miss that one. And this,
the sweeping psychedelic drug act
of 1970 they missed five meo DM.
This is what I had bought at Colorado
River town. Yeah, that's the motherfucker.
Good thing you didn't look at them. Yeah,
because you wouldn't have Google it.
You will just, Oh I have Google
back then. I don't think,
I think this is right before I moved here.
Well anybody listening,
please don't lick the toad
cause you can die and don't,
don't like poison this dark dark frogs.
Yeah. But if you take that stuff
and you smoke it, it's DMT.
You will trip your fucking
balls off if you smoke.
The shit that comes from that toad skin,
which is really kind of crazy.
The difference between that
and Psilocybin is very similar.
The silicide been also is
an end dimethyltryptamine
it's got that and something
else.
So since uh,
siliciden is like four Fox for
Loxley and and dimethyltryptamine.
So the, the, the last part of it is
dimethyltryptamine then five MBO diamonds,
a trip to me,
which is what these frogs have is diamond
field trip to me with like an oxygen
mile molecule attached to it.
So it has a different impact.
But all that shit that's like prevalent
in children's books and folklore,
like all those elves when you see like if
at that guy's name is towed and
he has a mushroom head. Yeah.
And he has the head of the mushroom.
That sounds cool. I was telling you, I,
I think that's the people that
are making books for kids.
You gotta kind of have had a mushroom
trip to really want to help kids,
you know, and it's kind of like, like,
oh, that's crazy. I don't know man.
There's a lot of mushrooms, a little, they
don't have to trip on my, I don't know,
but I swear to God,
I watch a lot of educational
TV for children and they
bring up mushrooms a lot.
What is this? It's a mushroom and
it's a red mushroom. It's like why?
There's so many other things
you could have brought up.
You're talking about mushrooms
just trying to teach it.
Mushrooms come up a lot and
children's books and in their TV.
I don't know what it
mean for Mario Brothers.
Well, look at what, yeah,
we'll think about Lewis Carroll
and think about Alison Wonderland.
It was all about acid.
Yeah. Right now there's billboards
everywhere. All over La.
There's a new show called wonderland
or something, and as a guy and a girl,
they're looking at each other's eyes and
the background. All of these mushrooms,
red hat, red tops, like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Those mushrooms are what they believe
to be Santa Claus because it even looks
like Santa Claus. Yeah,
those mushrooms also,
this is where it gets really crazy if
you haven't heard the whole spiel before.
They are, they're there. They
have a symbiotic relationship
with coniferous trees,
like pine trees that
grow under pine trees.
They have a Michael Rise will relationship
with the soil like the those trees.
That's where those things always grow.
They feed off of each other,
so this fucking thing is
always underneath these trees,
just like brightly colored gifts that
are always underneath Christmas trees.
Why are Christmas trees always pine trees?
Why do Christmas trees have these
ornaments hanging in them? You know,
because he's taken these mushrooms.
He was to pull them out of the bottom
of these trees and then hang them in the
tree to dry them out.
The other way they drove with dried them
out was they would have them in front
of fireplaces.
That's why socks are white and red.
Christmas socks or white and red. Who
the fuck has white and red sox? Nobody.
Why would you hang your socks in
front of the fireplace like that?
Because that's how they
dried out mushrooms.
They used to tie into strings and dangling
from a fire and that's how they dried
them out.
That's how the preserved them.
It's like everything about it has to do
with Shamans and everything about it has
a connection to this mushroom. And
that mushroom was like synonymous. The,
the Amanita miscarry and mushroom was
synonymous with reindeers because reindeer
love those fucking thing.
Reindeer or Caribou live in Siberia.
That's where they live up there.
And these motherfuckers,
when you're in there like a showman's
hut and they're all like eating Amanita
Musk area mushrooms and having
these tribal ceremonies,
they would go outside to pis and the
Caribou would literally knock them over to
get to their pis because they're pissed.
Had Avenue to miscarry a smell to it.
Damn Hamilton Morrison did it on vice.
Of course he did.
He's done everything on the show, right?
You puke a lot. Uh, this is the Amanita.
Yeah, there's part one, two and three.
Oh, he's done it on the frogs.
Well, there's another type of fraud.
If he shows a scar does it, different
thing. There's another type of frog.
We take the venom of the frog and you,
um,
you cut yourself and you,
uh,
take this toads venom and you put
it like directly into your skin.
And somehow or another by doing that,
by doing it,
I think they burned themselves like
they burned themselves to like with ash,
like a an ember and then they put the
frog like so it opens up the pores and
they put the frogs venom right into
them and they have this transcendent,
transcendent, transcendent
experience. Is that Hamilton Morris?
My stomach is in excruciating pain.
He's such a freak in me.
I love this guy's got a frog. Yeah, yeah.
See they burn you and then
they stick this shitting on you
and your trip, your balls off.
Go meet with the spirit world.
But you know there's people throughout
history have come up with a bunch of
different methods to
transcend normal reality,
normal consciousness,
and in different parts of the world.
When they were stuck in some
area that didn't have mushrooms,
they figured out what Datura does. They
figured out what, you know, what is this?
What does this cactus do if you light it
on fire, you know, what does this Bush,
what's in this Bush? People have
been finding that stuff forever.
These scholars in Jerusalem think that
that was what Moses was seeing when he
went to the burning Bush. He saw
the burning Bush. That was God.
He gave him the 10 Commandments.
They believe that was DMT
because the bush has done,
they have like the Acacia Bush, very
rich and DMT. It's all over that area.
Bush burning DMT, light, DMT on fire
get high. It's like it's so obvious.
He's expense.
I had with mushrooms is back in 2008 I
did five grams specifically five grams
weighted, put it in a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich and went to the zoo
and that was a bad choice. Decision fucked
up. It was a bad decision. I thought,
hey, we be with the animals and
to be all about love. We get that.
I went with the check and why we were
checking out the gorillas is when it hit
and all we wanted to do is just sit in
the shade and not look at the animals,
close her eyes and the visuals you get
are just amazing. When people say, oh,
that's in your head, you made that up
mine. There's no way. If I made that up,
it would be fragmented and all fucked up.
There's no way.
As soon as I closed my eyes,
there's a show waiting for me and it's,
in my opinion, there's no way I'm, I'm
doing this. If it was, if I was running,
the show would not look like that.
I have the ability,
but well,
that's the actual,
what they believe is that
what you're doing is you're,
you're hijacking your visual cortex
and so that these chemicals impact your
visual cortex and create this incredible
display because your body does not know
how to process what's coming in. That's
the idea behind it. It does. It does it.
What I've always said is it doesn't
matter because whether you're creating it,
whether it's real or not real,
it's still the same experience.
Whether it's real or not real, whether
it is real, when it breaks down to it,
you're actually seeing that.
So whether or not that's your
imagination is creating it,
that's how people like to dismiss things.
Oh, it's just in your imagination. No,
it's not. And it doesn't matter. Even if
it is because it's still the same thing.
It's still this insane, crazy
thing that you're looking at. Yeah.
So even if it is your imagination,
it's still the wildest fucking thing
you're ever going to see in your life.
So hard to explain. The, the only
way I can explain it is like,
it's like those visualizers on
your iTunes times a thousand. Yeah,
it's perfect. It's not broken
up to me, in my opinion.
Something else is creating it.
I don't know what it is,
but there's something is creating that
cause there's no way I can create this
amazing art and it's perfect and perfectly
symmetric and it's like snakes of
just crazy.
So after like five minutes of
just sitting there at the zoo,
we thought we had like a fear and loathing
in Las Vegas moment where we just had
to get out.
And I just,
we ran to the parking lot and it's at
the La Zoo and we're looking at the
mountains. I'm like, Oh, you're looking
at the mountain. Look at the mountain.
I instantly understood what all
the Aztec art was all about.
Like that's what they're seeing.
And I go,
you look at them at the mountains were
dancing. The guy who, who gave it to me,
he goes, dude, the clouds
are going to dance for you.
I thought that was a metaphor.
I didn't know he actually meant that.
And anytime you focus on something for
one second, you look at the clouds,
they start dancing for you all
perfectly. It's like, well, it's, Ooh,
it's a weird feeling because it feels
like something's there all the time.
You just can't see it. That's
what it feels like. Whenever
I've been on mushrooms,
like when I was talking about the,
um,
the one where Doug and I took the Amanita
miscarry and then the psilocybin. Yeah,
the feeling I got and it didn't last very
long because there was so many things
going through our head and it
was the day of the Iraq war,
the day the war started.
So it was a pretty freaky moment.
But I saw this honeycomb pattern in
front of me, like where everything I saw,
like the pattern of the universe.
And it like occurred to me like, oh,
this is here all the time.
I just don't see it and that's what it
feels like when you see those things
dancing. Absolutely. It was
incredible. It was so hard at,
that was the craziest drive home.
It was exact.
When I first time I saw fear and
loathing in Las Vegas, I thought, man,
this is so unrealistic.
It doesn't,
you don't see shit like
that when you get high.
I've been high planning
at times you don't,
but I understood it because the
drive home, I didn't know it was,
I should've been dead.
There's no way I should have made it home.
I didn't know if that was cars next to me,
that we're right here.
The it felt I was driving
through a jungle. It was cranberry.
You. You called me. He said, dude,
the road turned into flower pedals.
Yes. Like I was being guided by,
I was in a jungle and there was flowers
and and Green Moss and I'm driving
through it and I could see
the cars like in the distance,
but just in my little cube, my
little circle, I was in the,
in the forest when I should've been dead.
I don't recommend that. If you're
going to experiment with psychedelics,
I'll stay home, I'll stay
home. Cause what does it show?
The Fun and the great part of it is being
in a dark room and closing your eyes
and checking out the light
show in your head. That's the,
it's not like you pass out or anything.
Like if you smoked DMT,
you pass out and it's kind of
like you're in a dream state.
But with mushrooms you're completely
conscious. You could talking,
but as soon as you close your eyes,
it isn't like it takes a 10 1520 seconds
to dissolve into this show that the
instant you close your eyes,
it's right there waiting for you.
It's like right in front
of your eyes and it's deep,
five dimensional and it's perfect. There's
nothing breaking off. It's just it.
To me,
there were some intelligence behind it.
Well it certainly feels like
there's some intelligence behind it,
but the thing that's always struck me,
as weird as it always feels
like it's there all the
time. Like whenever I do DMT.
One of the weirdest things that
happens is this feeling like, oh,
I've been here before. Even before ever
did it. The first time I ever did it,
I was like, I've been here before. I
know this place. Like I know this place.
You know it's, I don't know why with
the mushrooms. Awesome. All those.
It seems like all those who listened, they
did. Like I said, I've done this before.
Well, one of the reasons mo most likely
is that mushrooms and DMT on these,
all these things like mimic
human neurochemistry. So w the,
the real wonder is what's happening
to you while you're sleeping?
What's happening to you for that
six to eight hours, whatever it is,
where you're out cold,
they don't really know.
But they do know that the human
mind mimics the reactions to, to,
to a diamond field trip. To me, not only
does it produce diamond field trip to me,
but it produces similar reactions like
dreams. When you're done with a dream,
it's hard to remember it. You
know? You know how that is.
Yeah. You know, it's weird,
man. It's like the dream is so amazing.
I, I've said to myself too, like, oh,
I don't have to write this down cause
I'm gonna remember it cause I'm a lazy
bitch. I don't want to get up and
write something down. I'm like,
I'm not going to forget this.
And then I wake up in the morning like,
what the fuck was it? I don't
remember it at all. Forget. Yeah,
DMT is the same way you do DMT and
the dream, just whatever it was,
whatever the experience was
disappears like in the morning,
you can't remember it or when it's over
or rather you can't remember it. Well,
how about when you're dreaming, you
don't remember reality. Exactly right.
It's true.
You don't remember it so much that your
uncle could be David Cassidy is fine
with it. Yeah, man do. I could
totally cool with it. You're
not going. Wait a minute.
How the fuck is he? My uncle?
He's my uncle. The Partridge
family. Wait a minute.
We had a dream like David Cassidy.
Yeah,
like random people would show up in
my dream and you accept you don't,
you don't remember.
You remember this dimension as much as
you remember your dream state when you're
in this dimension. So it's like, man,
what, what is it really? And when you,
when you think about like
that were all empty space,
you know that quantum
theory where you know,
at the subatomic levels we're
99.99, nine, 9% empty like this,
this is empty your, this, your
body's empty to how is that possible?
It's solid.
How is it possible that this is empty?
When you look at it at the subatomic
level, how is that possible?
It's so hard to wrap your brain around.
Well, we had that unmet go swami guy.
Yeah, I heard that. Great. Great podcast.
Did you understand a word he was saying?
Some of it,
some of it I faked it through.
So I wonder if it has like the reason this
is solid. I wonder, you know, cause uh,
electro magnetic energy is running
through everything, right? So that's,
it seems like it's must
be powering everything.
Like where do we get our electricity?
We're plugged into the universe
house and according to science, uh,
were just flooded with electromagnetic
energy and it's just running through
everything.
So it seems like that's how we might be
plugged in and that's what's giving us
the power because it's not our
muscles that are, are doing anything.
It's the electric pulses
that are doing it.
That's where you're getting your strength
from and that's what's running your
heart. You know, your heart isn't just
beating there. It's connected to this,
this ocean of electromagnetic
energy that we're in.
So for electoral magnetic energy
magnets might have something to do it.
So I'm thinking, you know, when you,
you try to put a magnet together,
there's like nothing there,
but it's solid.
Like maybe the subatomic
particles that were created, it's,
maybe it's solid because it's
really just a magnet in a,
in its own little unique form. Like
it's really not there. It's not,
but the way it's the, the photons or
whatever, I'm just making shit up.
I'll put together the way they're put
together. It's a certain form of magnet.
Like this is this kind of magnet. It's
the skin magnet, but it's really not.
They're just like, when you try to put
it on back fucking talking about, well,
we're all empty space.
I'm trying to get the magnet thing.
When you tried to put
two magnets together,
you can't because it's like you don't
see anything there, but you just can't,
it just something solid, Ken, if you
flip it. But you know what I'm saying?
That there's nothing there
yet. It's solid. Like they're
saying something's there.
Maybe,
maybe since we're all a running through
electromagnetic energy now this is just
my crazy stone theory.
Maybe it has some because people are
baffled or the top scientists don't even
know what the fuck. Like how was this
empty space? How was this empty space?
When it's solid to us, maybe it
has something to do with, uh,
like particles being magnetized.
Who knows?
You know,
the points are just theories.
The point is there's this matter
in a book anywhere. The reality,
the reality of quantum mechanics,
this is what we absolutely know is that
particles can be in a state of super
position, which means that they're moving
and they're still at the same time.
Yeah. They blink in and
out of existence. They,
we have no Orleans of times
per second and particles from,
you know,
here could,
they could be on the other side of the
planet and they react instantaneously if
faster than the speed of light.
They split out of that.
They'd done experiments without
split up a photon, whatever they,
and they separated by
14 miles or whatever.
One experiment was 14 miles there in
different labs and whatever they did to
this, half of the Photon, the other
half reacted in the exact same way.
So that's the lag with no lag at
all. They don't understand it. Yeah.
So just that alone is like,
that's science fiction.
Those are all the blink in
and out of existence. Yeah.
Like Shit, how does it work?
I think there's something way more to
this world than we're ever going to be
able to wrap our heads around with
what are our crude minds and bodies can
perceive of the reality that we exist in.
Yeah.
I think we have this idea that the
reality of the we exist in the measurable
reality we exist in is all there is.
Yeah,
but I think there's probably a whole
soup of possibilities that we're swimming
in. We don't know. We're not, we're not
interacting with it. We don't have the,
but we also know it exists. Like
that's Karma. You know that's love.
That's like the one that's momentum and
you start having good things go your way.
Good things tend to stay going your way
and it all sorts of feed into other good
things.
There seems to be like a way the universe
would like you to to react and behave
and it rewards you with
like a positive experience.
It rewards you with love and if you pay
attention to people that are living like
a fucking disaster of a life, the universe
is not rewarding them at every turn.
It's fucking them up, their cars
breaking down to getting arrested.
They're girl hits him in the head with
a fucking frying pan when of sleeping.
It's like a constant stream of shit keeps
coming their way until eventually they
either die or get locked up.
And it's like the universe is
setting that up as well. It's like,
it's like forwarding or not rewarding
the correct behavior or the incorrect
behavior. Life is so
perfect, so beautiful.
And so it's just incredible.
I mean,
as humans we have the intelligence to
make satellites and rockets and airplanes,
but we can't even make a flee.
We can't make a fleet.
We have no idea how that shit works.
Making an athlete that can
fucking check another fleet.
How can we can't make a tree?
Yeah, we can make a tree.
We think we've got to figure it out.
We think there is no higher
intelligence out there.
Some kind of something come on. It
might even just be law, you know,
it might just be a law of the universe
or um, you know, instead of a law,
like an equation,
like you know,
positive and love and this and that
and moves towards this direction,
negative and horrible and evil
moves towards that direction.
And it's almost like the two need each
other to do battle back and forth and to
empower to empower the other.
Absolutely. Esther Hicks says, you know,
it makes sense like you were here.
Who knows if this is true.
This is just something that someone said
that it's seems pretty awesome to me
that it seems that we're here,
we're existing,
we're supposed to feel the
pain because if we don't feel
the pain,
we're not going to appreciate the good
stuff and it's not going to feel as good.
Like she uses an example of your best
meal is always eaten when you and your
hungriest and that totally makes sense.
Like if you're never hungry,
you won't really give a fuck about food.
If you're born a billionaire,
you don't care about money,
you don't care about what it can buy.
And so it's almost like we need,
we need the pain where it's almost
like we're here for the pain. Well,
there's certainly like reward systems
built in and it seems like if you look at
it like all the animals on this planet,
at least there is a struggle that's
going on constantly. Nobody lives easy.
Everybody's struggling.
You're struggling to find food,
just struggling to keep off
predators is struggling to keep your,
your young alive.
And it seems like it's set up that way.
And it seems like it could
be way easier if, uh,
there was like total harmony
in the animal world. Well,
isn't it like life and success,
like what they're looking for when they
all just be fucking eating plants, when,
that'd be like the best way
to go about it. But no, it's,
it seems like the struggle is built in to
the whole code of life.
Yeah.
When there's a battle to try to
figure out how to do it right. Well,
we want the struggle and
a lot of things in movies.
We don't want to go to
a movie where nothing,
there's no conflict or nothing
bad happens. That would
be the worst movie ever.
The greatest movies are the ones that take
you down to the depths and you buy it.
You are and you've,
you suspend your disbelief in,
you're down there and then you come up
with it and the stories believable and
you lose yourself in the movie, but
without the conflict, the movie sucks.
Do you worry about that with your kid
like in a certain way? I do with my kids,
it's like I don't want my kids
to experience a lot of adversity.
Just you want to protect your children.
Yeah,
but I know that all the people that I
know that experience adversity or the most
interesting people, you know,
all the people that we know,
think about all the people that who
know look thinkers like Joey Diaz.
He's one of the most interesting
guys at right because this,
his life was completely crazy.
Like his life was full,
total chaos. Like the adversity you
had to go through the adversity.
I had to go through the adversity.
Cowen had to go like all the people
that we know that are interesting.
They all had kind of a fucked up life.
Yeah.
What's that about?
Do you think that you could get away with
just exposing your kid to a difficult
things like Jujitsu,
like uh,
exposing them to martial arts and maybe
they could develop their character that
way without having to go through the,
the horrible
ups and downs of,
I don't know if Jujitsu
promotes or guarantees a great sense
of humor and the ability to make other
people laugh.
But the one thing in my experience that
I know that Jujitsu does for children,
absolutely, and it's, it's
has a lot to do with you.
W you always talk about it when a kid
doesn't have martial arts and Jujitsu
specifically because of the
tapping and getting capped out,
what that shows you that automatically
in Jujitsu, you know where you stand.
You know where you stand,
you know that you're a blue belt,
you're probably not going to be purple
belts that much, but when you do,
you'll get your purple belt and you're
probably not going to beat brown belts
and black belts that much in the
beginning. But when you start doing it,
then you get your brown belt
and so on and your black belt.
So when a kid comes into Jujitsu,
he's four years old, five years old,
he knows that he's not going to,
it rarely gonna beat the seven year olds.
And when he's seven he's rarely
going to be at the 10 year olds.
So that teachers, if they don't go
through that, there is a possibility.
Not always. There's plenty of great
kids that have never done Jujitsu,
but what I've seen with Jujitsu kids,
it almost guarantees that they won't be
delusional and become a douchebag kid.
Because if you don't,
if you're not checked that way with a tap,
like reminding you that
this guy is 15 years old,
you better respect that 15 year old.
And then what ends up happening
is when you become 15 you,
you know what it was like going through
the early stages of Jujitsu. So you,
I see kids that are 10 and 11 are great
with the five year olds and great with a
six year olds.
It takes you out of that delusionary
state and let you know that you better
respect your elders and as you get older
you better respect the kids too because
they're going to get older too. So what
you did to really does is people put,
it instills discipline in you.
Like A,
most people think martial arts does
like karate and taekwondo and that
definitely works too because
it does promote discipline.
But Jujitsu does it I think
better because of the tapping.
Most kids that I know
that are good at Jujitsu,
they have a tremendous
relationship with their father.
It brings them tighter traveling all
over the world like I do to all these
seminars. Um, oh,
I don't know how many times I've met
kids is Jujitsu phenoms that are eight,
nine years old.
And their dads bring them to Jujitsu
and they're best friends Avery down in,
um, uh, and uh, uh, he used to be
a Springfield. Now he's an Oma,
he's 16 now. Him and his dad
are best friends. And when I'm,
when I run into them like,
man, give me advice. You know,
what else did you do? Cause there it just,
you see it over and over again. So, um,
for those of you with kids out there
and maybe you're having trouble with the
kids, try to talk them into Jujitsu,
you know, it, it might be hard,
but I think that if you're having trouble
with your kids or you want to insure a
beautiful relationship, tight
relationship, a trusting
relationship and you know,
relationship where the kid,
your kid wants to hang out with
his popping and you did you just,
until you do it with your kid,
that that's just a little something that
I've learned. That's a little insight.
You can take that for what it is.
I, I, I'm just, I'm just trying to,
if anything the kid can
do that's difficult.
It's good for their
personality development.
One of the real problems with kids
today's cause everything's handed to you.
You don't develop character because
you don't ever face adversity.
Your food comes from a supermarket.
You can go to a store and get whatever
you fucking need. You know, it's not hard.
It's, it's, it's easy to live life.
And so when, when you're not tested,
especially as a young person,
like a lot of bullying comes
from and people say like,
what's the best way to stop bullying?
I always say the best way to stop
bullying is teach kids how to fight.
If you had like mandatory Jujitsu classes,
if you had mandatory martial
arts classes in school,
you would have a whole lot less
bullying because first of all,
that they wouldn't be inclined to do
it. And second of all, it wouldn't work.
Like if a guy is talented and skilled and
he's 155 pounds and there's an asshole
that's 180 pounds, it's fucking
with them. He's not gonna back down.
They're going to figure
out a way around it.
The kid's going to be able to figure
out a way like, listen, you know,
if you want to fucking fight,
you want to be an asshole and pick on me.
I have to fucking defend myself.
Then I'll defend myself.
But it's not like is going to be
terrified, not know what the fuck to do.
It's going to be a completely
different scenario.
And I think that one of the reasons
why people do it in the first place is
they're trying to, they're trying to
prove that they aren't scared themselves.
The reason why people are bullies where
they have that instinct is they're
insecure. They're trying to
be dominant without, you know,
without putting in the work. But if
you put in the work, if you do Jujitsu,
if you were in a martial law,
he actually develops and proficiency.
You don't have that need. You don't
have that need to dominate people.
You don't have to know. You get it all
out, you get it all out in the gym.
All my boys were wrestling
the wrestling team.
So that kind of like know
wrestling's different dressings,
a sport and probably
they're just sick or you
know, where you're, I mean,
did you have bullies growing
up? Not really. I mean, uh,
I was bullied before I started doing
martial arts, but from like 14 on,
not really cause I was like thinking
about like all my bullies were all guys in
sports, like football team wrestling the
time I wrestlers. Yeah, with bullies.
In what way? Like how were you bullied?
You know, like just pushed her out on the,
the playground and stuff like that.
And like what year are you talking about?
Middle School. Elementary and middle
school used to trip you a trip.
You like when you're
walking ticked with, yeah,
I was fucked with a lot. But then
like in high school and it went away.
It's a douchebag move,
man.
Be a bully. It's one of the worst
things a person can do. Yeah, it's a,
it's a weird, natural human
weakness. So weakness,
instinct to like fuck up.
Picky.
Yeah. My shit was mostly cause evo. My
parents were divorced and I was poor.
I think it was that big.
Why they picked our meme.
It's they pick on you because you were
poor. Yeah, cause I lived in Worthington,
which is a higher end place in Columbus,
but I was like living on that one part
that was all apartments. That was,
it shouldn't have been in there,
you know?
But somehow I was in Worthington so
they knew I was poor and my parents were
divorced back then. Back then divorce.
It wasn't as crazy as it is now.
Where you know was unusual. Yeah,
a little bit more unusual. Yeah.
Isn't that weird that
like when we're younger,
people didn't bother getting divorced or
they didn't happen nearly as much? Not,
not in my neighborhood.
Everybody got divorced.
All my friends didn't have fathers.
All of them except one. Norio Galvin.
He's the only one out of maybe 15
friends that we had gone up. Everyone,
every father left in a really
poor neighborhood was all Mexican.
You grew up in Mexicans believing
they get drunk and go back to Mexico
and say, fuck that. Yeah.
Isn't that weird man?
When people that don't take take care
of their kids as a father now it doesn't
have freak you out. Yeah
man, I can't imagine me out.
My father had 19 kids from
eight different chicks,
God 19 is he still alive?
I don't know.
What kind of crazy hell does that guy
live in when he closes his eyes and one of
the last,
the last time I saw him,
I was 27 and he my my on my mom's side,
my mom's mother and father,
they stayed together to the very end.
They were married 50 plus
years and had 10 kids.
And my dad told me first he told me that
at 14 I saw him at 14 then I saw him at
27 at 14 tries to shove advice down my
throat and he said, make sure your Mary,
when you marry your wife,
she's at least 15 years younger than you.
He told me that. I remember
that. And he also said he also,
and my wife was 15 years younger than me.
It wasn't strategic,
but it just happened that way.
And the other thing he told me at 14
was be nice to kids cause they grow up
really fast and they'll turn into adults.
So he was trying to give me the right
advice and then at 27 I haven't seen him
in forever.
I thought he was dead.
He shows up one day and am I at my
grandpa's house? He goes, do what?
He's old and he's like, do what your
grandfather did. That's the way.
Have kids every Christmas and Thanksgiving
he has all his family and all his
grandkids. That's the way I had to
do it over. I would do it that way.
That's what he said.
And he was,
I want to some player and just banging
everything and just getting everybody
pregnant. Wow. That's so
sad. That's a sad life man.
Yeah. And I asked him, I go, what made
you want to come by this time? I was like,
he hadn't been around and I just,
I heard he showed up to my grandfather's
house and he had been friends with my
grandfather while he was messing with
my mom and him and my grandfather got
along and my aunt, Congress, your
dads get over here now. Your Dad's,
it's your grandma's. And
I'm an, I'm in Hollywood.
I'd drive down to Orange County and the
whole drive down. I'm like, I'm just,
I'm not going to give him a hard time.
I hadn't seen him in like 13 years and
I'm not gonna give him a hard time.
I'm just going to start over. I get,
I get another chance with my father.
I was like dry.
It was a long drive,
like an hour drive and show up at my
grandma's house and I'm happy you got a
smile. I'm like, damn,
I thought he was dead.
I'd have dreams of him dying and he's
is this really is right here. Shit,
let's go out to eat. Like we went to
black Angus in Tustin. My mom went,
we're all sitting there like, fuck
that. We get a second chance. Meanwhile,
I'm all happy to see my
father and I rarely, you know,
my mom wants to see me more than
I actually drive down and see her.
But now I want to start another
relationship with my father.
So then I asked my father,
uh,
and at this point I didn't know
about his 19 kids at this point,
if I've got five kids from, uh, I
knew he was married, had five kids,
and he was seeing my mom and on the
side I knew that my mom was a side grow.
That's what I do at this point. And I
said, why did you come by this time?
I'm curious each. And I was expecting
them to say, it's been so long.
I wanted to see what happened. You
know, what's become a view? And he said,
ah, just I was passing
through Orange County and,
and I wanted to see if your
grandfather was still cool with me.
I didn't know if he was mad
at me or anything and I just,
I just kept a smile on and bright.
They're right there.
I looked at my mom and I'm like,
fuck this dude. Fuck this guy. I'm a,
I'm going to spend time with my mom.
Fuck that dude.
And just kept a smile on it right there.
I made the decision.
I will never see this guy ever
again, and I never did, but less.
So during that dinner, he did say, Hey,
one of the two of his kids live in La,
the ones from that family, he goes,
they want to have dinner with you.
They want to meet you. So I did end up
meeting with them, never saw them again.
They're the ones who told me.
They sat me down at the old spaghetti
factory in Hollywood when I was 27 and
they go, do you have any idea how
many kids your father has? I said,
five plus me.
He has 19 kids. I still, how
did that happen? He goes,
he got, not only did,
did they know about it,
he told his family about every
kid and every girl he was seeing,
he was trying to drive his
wife insane to get a divorce.
She wouldn't divorce him. She was hardcore
Catholic. So she wouldn't divorce.
He wanted a divorce. He wanted,
uh, uh, to, to marry my mom.
That's what he says. But she wouldn't
give him a divorce. So he would tell her,
they knew all about me. He goes, he
would come home and just say, oh,
Marty has pregnant now all muddy.
I had the baby, we named it Ed God.
He would come home to his wife, to his
wife and kids and say, oh, Maria had,
had just got pregnant. We just had
our kid, I'll be gone for the weekend.
I'm gonna spend time with my son.
So I actually spent my mom,
my dad had my mom in an apartment
promising that he would leave his,
my mom thought he was going to leave
his, his wife, his wife for her, for her.
She was in love and he never did, but he
had her in an apartment in downtown La.
And then after like three years,
got,
apparently I lived with them for three
years. My mom just said, enough's enough.
She went back to Orange County,
back to her parents' house.
And that was the end of that weird thing,
isn't it?
The idea that someone could just do that.
When you have kids now and you,
you know, I know you, you
know, you get on a plane,
we were talking about you
leave your house. No, you're
going away for the weekend.
You miss them as soon as you get in
your car. Yeah, just start driving away.
But this guy could just abandon this kid
and then see you and not even have like
a connection with you and be like,
God,
I just want to see if your
grandfather was mad at me. Yeah.
And then when I talked to them,
when I had that,
when they told me about the 19 kids,
they, it started to make sense. I'm like,
no wonder he didn't give a fuck about me.
Now I understand the kind of 19 kids.
How can you, he was, you know,
it was never a dick to me.
When he would see me once a year, he
would cruise by. Did he hug you? Ah,
maybe a little not, but I found out that
he never said I love you had a prior.
He never told any of his kids. I
love you. Never said I love you.
So he had something really
wrong with them. So then it
all became clear like, oh,
this guy has no love in him.
That's why he just keeps having kids
with whoever and he doesn't really care.
He was never a dick to me. He just didn't
really like care that much about me.
It's Kinda weird because that's
sort of like if look at nature,
if you look at the programming of
the human animal then that's like the
programming. The programming is to
spread your seed as much as possible.
The programming is to have
as many babies as you can.
The program has not for the male
to take care of them though.
It's really strange.
You know,
the program is to keep going to keep
spreading that seed and that's one of the
reasons why they say that.
Um,
like the intensity of her attraction,
like it goes away within a
few months of meeting someone,
like the intensity when
you first meet them.
That intensity of attraction for a man
goes away with within the first five or
six months because usually by then the
woman's already pregnant in nature.
You've been banging her, you know,
every day for several months.
One of the days she's been operating,
you shot one in there and ensured this
intense bond. You know, initially too,
to make sure that you continue to having
sex as much as possible to increase
your odds of getting them pregnant.
And then all of a sudden this weird
thing kicks in where you want to
go. Sometimes I kicked him and as soon
as you not post, not syndrome baby.
Yeah, but it's, it's, it's a weird, yeah.
Dang that,
that nature is literally set up that way.
And so in order to conform to what
society expects from a person,
you have to fight against your genetics.
You have to literally fight your instinct,
your instinct to fuck other girls,
their instinct to shoot loads into them.
I get them pregnant.
Weird. Remember? Do you remember
that when we worked on the man show,
that sketch I wrote
for pulseless syndrome.
It was a pill that you could
take that, uh, or you could,
you could have sex with a girl
and not get posted on syndrome.
If you take it 30 minutes before Sachs.
I don't remember that.
And obviously it never, it never got green
lighted, but that just reminded me of,
because that was a pill, right.
That is a real thing with men now.
Plus Syndrome is serious.
It's the feeling that you have.
Like right after you called me, like,
oh my God, I gotta get Outta here.
I gotta get Outta here. And if you don't
have that, that's when you know, like,
Hey, I think he's calling
somebody and she's cool.
I think I found a real
relationship. You're like, Hey,
let's go get something to eat. Or what
do you say? Don't leave. Let's watch TV.
What are you saying? What Spooner?
What are you saying? What after I come,
I just want to spirit and
snuggle with every chick. Yeah.
And then wake up and do it again.
More half retarded. It's different.
You know those girls, if you have sex
with and they're really dumb and you go,
oh my God,
why did I do this?
And you just want to jump down to when
he's as smart as them. So it's perfect.
[inaudible] they match
perfectly. They talk about shoes.
They sit there and talk about who's fat.
Girls don't really get posted on syndrome
unless they're married or something
and you know, then they feel
guilty. But if they're not married,
if they have sex with you, they,
they, they fall more in love with you.
All that depression, that depends entirely
on what the experience was like. Yes,
you're right. More than guys get
posted on syndrome way more than girls.
It's also the guys that we know too. We
know a bunch of savages. If you compare,
like we went to an accountant's
meeting, you know, and said, hey,
how you guys feel after you
come. But you know, people,
some people managed her talking to him
about sex. It's a weird thing when dudes
start talking like you and I have done
this before, we won't name any names,
but we've had sex conversations around
square dudes and you watch them panic
like they absolutely panic.
You know like they don't know what the
fuck does say like how often you fuck
your wife be serious.
Some guys a tell you like fuck
my wife like three times a week.
No more than that. Like I don't want to
fuck her everyday but I fuck her a lot.
And some guys would just go,
what? They just, they just
cleaned him up twice a day.
I can't or they will
say I can't know what,
it's just not something that I discuss.
Like you don't discuss how often
you bang your wife with another man.
Like why wouldn't you discuss that?
Do you not love your wife?
If you love your wife, you have sex
with you. Why? So is that off the books?
You can't talk about it like what do you,
I'm not,
I'm not asking you like specific details.
You know, what's crazy about my
wife is before the kid, you know,
once you, once you going out with
a girl for a year or two years,
you come home from Jujitsu.
My classes are kind of late.
A lot of times I'm broken.
I just went to war for an hour with
guys from out of town trying to tap me.
I come home,
I'm going to drink a protein shake,
I'm going to get on the
Internet a little bit.
I'm just going to collapse and
die generally after Jujitsu. So,
um, you know, for a while there, you know,
it's like I have sex tomorrow.
You just keep putting it off
and you don't have sex as much.
And then when you have a kid now you can
only have sex when that baby's asleep.
Right.
So now I really can't have it that much.
So I wanted way more than ever g cry
easy with the voice in the microphone one
or to way more than no. Yeah.
Oh yeah. I like it. I liked it.
The one thing I learned in my old age,
the one thing I learned,
because I've dated girls that didn't,
some girls didn't want
sex as much as I did,
and that would kind of Piss me off. I'm
23 and it's like, man, this is bullshit.
I should, I should get whatever I wanted
to. You're my girlfriend. Why are you, oh,
you're tired. Like it would, I would
get pissed off. And I'm like, man,
I want a girl that wants to fuck
anytime I want it. You know? So,
but then you have girls, and I've
had most of the girls were, uh,
wanted it more than I did. I was always
the tired one. And they always want it.
Morning. I get to the point where it's
kind of bothersome. I'm like, damn,
she wants it way too much. But now looking
back at all that and where I'm at now,
yeah.
Looking back at that now,
I would rather want it all the time and
rarely get it then always get it and
rarely won it. That's the one. Yeah,
that's definitely better. Yeah. As long
as you are still getting it. Yes. No.
Do you see this state Chell son and
Vandelay Silva going to host tough Brazil,
the ultimate fighter of reserve effect
Chels son and is going to go to fucking
Brazil. That crazy ass hole I have
to all the shit that he talked on,
Brazilians and Vandelay Silva and shale
has been like putting like these rhymes
up on his, uh, on his Twitter account.
Is it going to be an English or Brazil
and the Brazilians are going to be,
it's going
to be a Americans fighting
against Brazilians.
16 Americans will go to war to find eight
guys and then 16 Brazilians will go to
war to find eight guys.
That might be the greatest time.
Those two teams they might have. So a lot
of extracurricular violence. You know,
you gotta be careful of your,
your coaches. Chell son.
And he said a lot of nasty shit. Excuse
me. A lot of nasty shit about Brazilians.
Liam.
He's just talking trash is all he's doing.
And if you asked him honestly off the
record, he'd say they're great fighters.
It's a,
it's an honor and all that jazz.
But he talks so much mad shit
and Vandelay wants to kill him.
Vandelay and he was going to
be a car Raisie fight. Man,
that's going to be crazy.
As long as we handle is healthy.
I don't want to name any names
or any seasons or anything,
but apparently there's been some stuff
on the ultimate fighter that happened
behind the scenes. It was so violent
that they didn't want to air it. Really.
Have you heard about that?
Like fights? Yeah, like Pete,
there had been fights that they just
completely edit out. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
I believe it.
I believe it dudes get crazy.
They had to have them all still
living in houses together. They, yup.
This season they have girls
and guys living together.
Eight girl fighters and it's
a great season. This year.
Season is awesome at house.
Must smell so bad.
That's protein far clean.
That shit. Dirty guy.
It definitely, definitely, probably smells
bad. Are you watching the season? Yeah.
It's good to Rama between
those two chicks, man, jasmine,
Duke and what was the girl she fought?
Raquel Pennington or something.
Was that her name? I'm not sure. But
she can hit. Ah, but you're, you're,
yeah, yeah, yeah. I didn't see girls
names. Yeah. But Jasmine, Duke man,
talk about heart. She was getting
hit hard and she kept calling back,
throw a nice throw him down.
And she's,
she's actually more of a Jujitsu
chicken and she has a striker and man.
Talk about heart. She's a, um,
out in la now. Training with, uh,
Ronda Rousey's team. Dude, you got
to come down to the one in December,
the UFC in December, December 28th, which
we'll come to Vegas. You got to come.
Okay. That's the, that's the one word Ron
is going to fight Misha Tate. Oh Shit.
Yeah. You gotta be there.
And it's also Chris Weidman,
Anderson Silva dose. Oh Damn.
I'm that. Yeah, you got, you gotta be
there. That when he should take fights,
Ronda Rousey and when they actually
step into the octagon. Oh my goodness.
That's good. That might, that might
be the most insane evening ever.
Marinette also, or is that the
18th or something like, ah,
let's find out who's Barnett. Funny
Maxx is fighting Travis Browne. Oh,
that's right. Shit, son.
Good fight. Fuck yeah, it is.
Yeah. Let me see. Um, to do, do, do, do,
so it's front snap kicks that are
coming back strong, aren't they? Yeah.
They don't want to add on those.
Yeah. It's crazy. Isn't it weird that,
that that technique by Earl even existed?
Do you remember us going over it in
your garage and put it on mastering the
system?
And I remember asking him about a go,
why haven't we seen the front snap
kicks so much hard land. Yeah.
And you were like, ah, it's
hard to generate power.
And you were throwing a couple on,
like when you were throwing like that
looks like it would hurt if it landed and
boom, right after that Anderson, uh,
drop couture with it or know
Anderson dropped veto, right.
Victoria and then Machita drop couture
and now everyone's throwing those snap
kicks. Yeah. Overeem goes down with them.
That's a big technique now. Yeah. Okay.
Let's see. Anderson fight card.
Anderson Silva Weidman too.
Oh my God. This is an amazing card.
Oh, Shonda rouse, he meets me.
Should take Travis Brown.
Josh Barnett. Oh Shit.
Let me some Thai tea bowel
versus Michael Johnson.
Chris Liebing versus Uriah Hall.
Oh Shit. Wait, wait, Chris,
listen, leave. And versus Uriah
Hall. How is that possible shit,
Chris Liebing as a one 85. They're
five. Uriah Hall. I thought you were.
I thought I was thinking you're a favor
by a hall. The winter ultimate five. Okay.
Dennis Seaver versus Manny Gambier
Aryan. Whoo. Oh my goodness.
Goodness. Just nets on it. Sweet. Oh,
see our bio design aura.
How'd he say it?
By her designer versus a Doomsday Howard.
Holy Shit.
Dustin [inaudible] versus
[inaudible] brand. Oh,
this card's insane.
Yeah.
It's December 28th. Jim Miller
versus for Breazeale come once. Damn.
Oh my God.
This is cards insane.
I think for Breesa Como lines is that
guy that hit that a badass triangle from
the mount? Maybe, but now. Yeah.
I wouldn't know that was Sergio.
Something's different types. I don't
know who did it. A different guy
either way.
What a fucking card.
Water card this weekend I'm going to,
uh, I'm headed to England.
Going to Manchester. UFC.
Yeah. Well, I'm going, I was
going to do that. Uh, blood
treatment thing in Germany,
but I'm an, I'm going to do it in Santa
Monica. They do it in Santa Monica.
What's the blood treatment? So stem
cell thing that guys do for their disks.
It's supposed to be
incredible for it's been,
that's the one thing that
kept me out of Jujitsu.
I've been like we were
talking about been uh,
injuries and you look forward
to getting back to Jujitsu.
Had been stitched up before.
I've had two knee surgeries and I
went back to Jujitsu at my nose fixed,
went back to new Gi Jujitsu
and everything's fine.
But this was a scary one when
you start getting numb hands.
And then we knew quite a few people that
have had like real serious issues with
their backs where they have atrophy of
their arms and a bus route and has one
arm that's like literally half the size
of his other arm. It's scary. So I'm not,
I wasn't down with any surgeries man.
I wanted to make sure that I did all the
right things as far as rehabilitate and
uh,
I got a lot stronger.
I came back that one day and rolled
pretty fucking hard and didn't have any
problems, but it was real stiff. And
um, the next day it was stiff and sore,
but I'm like at least I could roll.
I know I can roll,
but I think I can make this thing better.
You haven't rolled forward. Go back.
I'm enrolled sense mostly
been doing just Moitai and uh,
a lot of weightlifting,
which doesn't bother me.
It doesn't bother me with kettle bells
and it doesn't bother me with, um,
with [inaudible] it's just getting
my neck cracked in the day.
I came back to your, to the gym too. It
was all arm triangles. It was a member.
It was a arm triangle transitions and
gay teens, which is um, my favorite.
I love arm triangles, but God, Dan has
a lot of shit going on with your neck.
So how you feeling right now today?
Feel fine. It's stiff. My back stiff.
But that's just cause I lifted
weights yesterday. Pretty hard, man.
I hope that that works out for you.
Be Too. You got to do it too, man.
You gotta try that shit back feeling
great, but I would, it would make it easy.
It's not 100% right,
but it doesn't stop me from Roland
doesn't sound from training.
I just got to really focus on keeping
my hamstrings nice and stretch.
Never stretched my hamstrings ever.
That was,
that's the downfall of lower backs is,
is a tense and tight hamstring.
So that's a new thing of mine
where every morning I'm waking up,
I'm stretching my hamstrings before class,
after class. Sometimes, you know, I,
I, I don't have time, but I just,
I'm more committed to stretching my
hamstrings more than, than anything.
This is a stretch. This is what this stuff
is, that's important. But this is what,
this stuff it's called, it's
the, the way, uh, the, the,
the term is called regene. Oh, keen.
R. E. G. E. N. O. K.
I. N. E, a Ortho keen.
It's is the actual medical procedure
and you take, they take your blood,
extract it,
the manipulated somehow then reintroduce
it to the body as an antiinflammatory
drug to reduce chronic pain and arthritis.
And the process involves two ounces
of blood drawn from your arm and it's
incubated in a slightly
raised temperature.
The liquid is then placed in a
centrifuge until its constituents.
Parts are separated.
The middle yellowish layer is dense with
agents that are believed to stop our
and arthritic agent
known as Interleukin one,
which causes degeneration of the
joints and a breakdown of cartilage.
That serum is injected into
the patient's affected area.
The procedure reduces pain
and discomfort to the joint,
and the treatment generally lasts five
days with six shots of the serum into the
effected area.
It's normal for a patient
to receive annual injections
to ease joint discomfort.
So many pro athletes have done
this and had miraculous recoveries.
Peyton manning went to Germany for this.
He's,
he'd get two neck surgeries and he was
on his way out of football and now he's a
fucking superstar again.
He's having the best year of his life.
It's from this shit.
G Dana White did it and he's just raves
about the result of it. Supposedly level.
If you're, if you have arthritis in
your spine, your lower back, Louis,
hello from 10th planet. Montreal's got
this, he's got arthritis in his back.
A guarantee or this would help them.
I mean, I don't know how much he has.
I don't know what,
I haven't seen his MRI,
but I guarantee you that this will make
him feel better than he feels. Now.
I'm going to tell, I'll, I'll give
everybody breakdown of it. When I do it.
I start next week when I get back
from England, I go in, um, and uh,
we'll see what happens. You already had
all that shit done. Yeah. My, my Mri,
I had my MRI done right after the injury.
He looked pretty nasty man.
I had a six millimeter millimeter bulge
in my neck. It's pretty big. You know,
it's reduced now quite a bit, but right
after the injury it was six millimeters.
That's not good. And that's why I was
having numb hands and all that shit.
And you know, it's from,
it's from doing it,
getting injured and then taking a couple
of weeks off and jumping right back in.
That's what it is. Not allowing myself
to fully heal up and core strengthening,
core strengthening is massive.
It's so important. You know,
if you're going to be in there
throwing down on a regular basis,
you got to do some core workouts.
You've got to do something that keeps you,
gives you a little armor to protect
you from being injured. No squats,
squats, help a lot. Squats a wind,
mills Kettlebell, windmills are huge.
I love those. The exam, that is a
strengthening your entire core, you know,
all that bending and carrying
that heavyweight, Turkish
getups, that kind of shit.
You're doing any shows when you're
in England? I am doing two shows.
The dance house theater, they're
both sold out, so go fuck yourselves.
English people, they
bring it into late. No,
I'm going with a guy who
was a local kid and uh,
Dave Bishop, David Bishops.
Gonna. Oh, he's don't comedy
again. He can't. No, no, no.
He's going to just introduce us.
It's done. Go over there. Do you ever
like candy man? You just set them twice.
Don't pay. The third time will show up.
That's it.
This podcast is over.
Thanks to a legal zoom.com a couple
of seminars. Yeah, absolutely.
I'll keep it a second. Go to legal
zoom.com enter in the code name,
Rogan in the referral box.
Save yourself some money and audible.com
go to audible.com forward slash Joe and
save your so some money by getting a
free audio book and 33 days of audible
service,
over 150 different titles to choose from.
You will fucking love them. Thanks
also to [inaudible] dot com go to o,
n n I t used the code name Brogan and
save 10% off any and all supplements.
What's going on? A Bravo. I'm
going to be a 10th planet Uma.
November 9th I'm going to be
at 10 planet San Francisco.
November 23rd go to 10th Planet Judge
[inaudible] Dot Com get on the neat BW
forum, a message board for
all the Info in details. Uh,
my podcast is Eddie Bravo radio.
It's on iTunes and stitcher and do it.
Send me your seminars when you're
doing them. I tweet them for you.
I tweet everybody's dates. I tend to
want to bother you, but don't worry,
it's not a bother. People love it. They
want it. And anybody who's interested,
you know, it's, it's something to do. You
should, you should do it. It's a you'll,
you'll learn a lot. Seminars are awesome.
It's a great way to see a new, uh,
aspect of Jujitsu to check
out a different person's game.
And I know how much time and effort
you put into them. They're awesome.
They're great seminar shit. I've been
going to your seminars since. Damn.
What was the first one we did got down?
It was a long ass time ago. The first one,
I think
Colorado. Boulder. I'm old. We started
doing seminars with your comedy.
Yeah, we did one in Miami.
Miami. Dot. Oh yeah. Late.
Do you remember how crazy that rain
was? Yeah. I'll never forget that. Yeah.
We hit a wall of water in Miami that you
couldn't see anything in front of you.
We've got to stop on the freeway. The
whole freeway stopped dead for the rain.
It was fucking crazy.
Yeah, that was awesome.
I haven't did a seminar in Miami
and for Jesus, a lot of Jujitsu.
That was the last time. That was the last
time. There's a lot of Jujitsu in Miami,
eight 10 may in Miami. My budgets are a
lot of Brazilians, like a Miami weather,
so follow him on Twitter.
It's Eddie Bravo on Twitter or 10th
planet j j.com and come down to
headquarters. Um, and, and
as soon as I get this back,
shit settled out within the next month
or so, I'll be back on a regular basis.
I teach downtown.
Just email me for Info twister,
bravo@sbcglobal.net and we should,
yeah, once I'm back in man,
we should do some shit together.
We'll figure out some,
do some seminars in those same
place where I'm doing comedy. Let's,
let's work that out, that, that's
making it happen, bitch. Beautiful.
All right folks, we will be back
soon. Um, next week I got a,
Sam Harris is here next week.
Should be a lot of fun. Um, and uh,
someone else as well. I forget who.
Don't worry about it. It'd be good.
Don't sweat it. All right. Keep it
together. You're dirty freaks and uh,
I will be at the Irvine Improv
November 1st, second and third.
That's a,
the next day coming out that's available.
The river Cree in Edmonton
I think is sold out.
And then I'm in Vegas on December 28th
at the Mirage 27th or 28th which one is
that?
Which one is Friday?
I'm sure on December 27th at the Mirage
in Vegas with the one and only Joey
motherfucking Coco de is so
Holla at your boy. All right.
We'll see you fucks very soon.
We love the shit out of Ya and thanks
for all the love back. Big Kiss.
Thanks everybody came to Houston
this weekend too. Thank you.
Had a great fucking time.
Okay.